this past
week there was a huge story about
journalist andy no
going undercover into an antiva protest
being found out chased and beaten and
nearly killed
and this is a group of people that uh
have expressed their desire
to kill him and nearly beat him to death
only a few years ago they threw
milkshakes they left him bloody his his
teeth were you know blood in his mouth
he had blood in his ears
and they mock him and they laugh about
it and this was one of the rare times
the mainstream media actually came out
and had to say something bad about
antifa
and boy did they not like it in fact
rolling stone claimed that he was
grifting and manipulating the press
because it was very
damaging to their narrative well then
news broke
i believe it was last week or you know
the week before actually the weekend
before
um that someone was attacked by an
anti-foot group they claimed it was andy
no in their photos and no one was sure
whether it was andy no or not when word
came out andy issued a statement and
confirmed this
a lot of people weren't necessarily
surprised that antifa would
try to brutally beat a journalist let
alone andy no but there was a
heated debate probably i mean i'm
probably the only one who came out was
very critical
and you know i said yesterday's maybe i
was a little crude in my tweet about it
i can accept that by all means criticize
me for it but i stand by my opinion 100
my opinion was that i think andy would
be better served
leading the charge and not going down
personally but
feel free to disagree and that's what
we're gonna be talking about today among
a bunch of other things
we are hanging out with elijah schaefer
who has experience on the ground
reporting
uh not just covering antifa but the
capital riots as well
and uh we had a difference of opinion so
i thought why don't we have a longer
conversation about the idea
uh specifically about him with any no
but into the nitty gritty of covering
antifa what antifa
is what they do and proper strategies
for dealing with that among a bunch of
other things because i know that
you know you you you were criticized by
a lot of people for covering the the
6 riot the capital and there's a lot of
weird to say the least
yeah to say the least i mean and this
isn't the first pushback
obviously that we've seen where people
are are talking crap on reporters and i
think this is where i want to
give a little caveat here why i think
this is such a sensitive thing and maybe
why you saw the tribalistic emotional
response
to your opinion is because there's been
this sort of a blowback
towards these guerrilla journalists and
reporters from the left sort of making
them the problem it started with
uh i think i don't remember what her
name was but she was like a sort of
butch lesbian looking professor from
harvard wrote
a um like op-ed talking about how andy
known myself in our coverage
was sort of what was to blame for
inciting more riots and she sort of
blamed
the actual coverage of the events with
what was sort of like the copycat
shootings that happened around the
country that more people would see the
footage
be inspired by it and would continue to
enact upon it
and then we also have the intercept
video the hit piece per se that was a
major blowback
that was trying to make people say well
when you see the facts being recorded
ask yourself the question who's behind
the camera recording the facts
because the video is a lie apparently
right it's not coming from an ideologue
i mean so you stuck your finger in an
open gunshot wound really is what you
did here is that people are feeling this
sort of defense
altruistic emotional defense for these
people who put their lives on the line
then you know tim poole comes this
youtuber living in his mansion the
skater guy
and he gives a strong opinion and
everyone's always like shut up tim
you're just joining in the hate and i
think that's kind of sort of where we're
at right now is
a lot of people are not looking at this
from an intellectual perspective we're
not even talking about this
in a real way they're just about picking
sides and i hope people don't do that
when they listen to this there's a
fantastic mix between people who are
like
you have no idea what you're talking
about tim all you do is sit in a room
and then the other people saying
tim for 10 years you were on the ground
to the most dangerous places in the
world who are you to criticize someone
for doing the same thing and i'm like
okay so i guess both are wrong
but we'll we'll get into the
nitty-gritty of that and we'll break it
down i also want to point out for
everybody
who's wondering our internet did get
struck by lightning and getting verizon
to come out and fix it
is i don't even know how to just i'll
give you an analogy but
it's just impossible you know we can
call every single verizon phone number
in the book
they don't come out it took six months
to get the internet longer than that to
get it set up in the first place
so when uh we had one internet guy come
out because we have four redundancies
and they're all broken
and uh he came out he was like your
wires are fried man it must have been
like a lightning strike so we've got a
long fiber
fiber-optic cable that we can't repair
ourselves and they don't want to either
and so uh here we are with completely
broken internet for that reason but
this is recorded it goes up on itunes
and spotify so for whatever reason you
know you can't handle because the
interruptions
you know we're trying it's the best we
can do but uh we're gonna carry on the
conversation and it will be up on
all podcast platforms and don't forget
to go to timcast.com you can become a
member there we'll have a bonus segment
that's all
recorded and then uploaded after so it
should be fine but uh yeah and he's
chilling oh yeah yeah this is great good
conversation because
there's a big problem in the scientific
community where measuring
something can end up altering the
substance or the situation that you're
actually
trying to measure just the act of
measuring can disturb the system so i
wonder
if journalism does that especially when
like if someone's in somebody's face you
know
like electron behavior right i mean
talking about whether or not you're
monitoring it or not
you can have different patterns of
behavior and recording and i do agree
with that
and i think criticisms of people in the
media is are valid i think it's good to
criticize people
i think people getting emotional even
over this situation is foolish because
even if you pick sides or you like
people the whole point of disagreements
are that we can come to a better
conclusion and try to understand
really what is the better take at least
for ourselves for the country we seem to
have lost that as a nation
and i think people are so into who's
your favorite internet celebrity
your favorite e-boy or e-girl that they
forget these are real people this is a
real country i know it's shocker
but america is still a real country it
doesn't feel like it but we still are
i'm not entirely convinced we'll talk
about that too because we got a bunch of
other stories as well but uh lydia she's
pressing the button i'm in the corner as
well and i'm really intrigued for this
conversation i hate to see tribalism for
the right so hopefully we can knock some
of that out tonight
but before we get started my friends we
have a great sponsor we have virtual
shield make sure you go to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get a virtual private
network service security for you as you
browse the internet
thirty percent off for life three
dollars and forty nine cents per month
in fact they say enjoy 24 months of
online security from the world's easiest
and fastest vpn
for only 83.83 that's actually 68
off plus we'll get 30 off all add-ons
and other great discounts
on our other plans we're also proud to
announce that this month all discounts
are guaranteed for life that means 30
off for life as long as you're a
customer so if you're not familiar with
the vpn service it is a basic
layer of security for you as you browse
the web it makes it much more difficult
for hackers and governments spies and
just you know creepy people
from spying on your data tracking what
you do
and if you're going to be doing a lot of
work from home now that everyone's you
know remote
it's probably a good idea to have some
kind of defense there's a bunch of other
things that vpns can do
because you know when you sign into your
vpn you can actually make it look like
you're in germany
or france wherever and with that
i don't know a lot of people have
figured a lot of fun things to appearing
in other parts of the world
but ultimately i just tell people look
you lock your doors you lock your
windows because you want that security
when you go to bed at night you don't
really expect someone to break in
you know every day or all the time it
might happen but you do have that
security
so you should definitely check out
surfinginternetsafe.com if you want to
keep yourself safe
thanks to virtual shield for being a
sponsor of the show for so long and
don't forget to go to timcast.com become
a member
because there's gonna there's gonna be a
bonus segment after the show we record
these so you know our internet has been
struck by lightning
and it's basically down and we're doing
everything in our power to fix it but uh
again maybe y'all can tweet it verizon
and be like why aren't you fixing the
internet i don't know
but uh we'll have a bonus segment up and
we have the newsroom and the the new
website launching hopefully about a week
or two so it's coming
it's coming soon and uh it looks
beautiful it's brilliant so definitely
check out timcast.com become a member
let's talk about this this first story
and get into the nitty-gritty discussion
about andy now we have the story from
yahoo news
journalist andy noe says he was nearly
killed by antifa
while undercover at oregon oregon
protest conservative journalist andy
knows that he was chased and beaten by
antifa members while covering a protest
in portland oregon late last month
no who says he has focused for on
exposing antifa for years
said no journalist in america should
ever face violence for doing his or her
job
the attack occurred on may 28th while
noah's covering the ongoing protests
and riots in portland for a new chapter
of his book unmasked inside antiva's
radical plan to destroy democracy
in a twitter twitter thought on june 2nd
noah explained that he had to mitigate
risks
like other beat reporters would on the
field so he covered his face and eyes do
the job and stay alive
he told fox news his disguise began to
fall apart when riders noticed that he
had not been participating in throwing
projectiles at law enforcement
or trying to damage the central police
station the mob allegedly pulled his
mask off
and upon confirming his identity chased
him through downtown portland before one
caught up and repeatedly punched his
head in face
a video of the incident shared by the
willamette week by the willamette week
shows a group of masked individuals who
are mostly white banging on the windows
of the nines hotel
where noah was a temporary refugee was a
temporary refuge
before ending up in the emergency room
with multiple injuries i do
have to point out that this article
published by yahoo it's kind of
hilarious how they're like the
protesters were mostly white
because even though they don't like andy
they have to point out he is still a
person of color being beaten by white
people oh yeah just like a
weird he's also gay which is an
interesting like double
cultural marxist pointer that i hate i
hate taking that low road i really do
because it is so stupid but and i also
can i even
precurse this saying a son of refugee
immigrant parents
who fled communism to come here to have
a better life so i mean like
if you take their their totem pole of
oppression andy knows pretty far up
there
there's not a big difference between
antifa and fascism
and i know a lot of people are like
antifa's the real fascist like well you
know they're not
nationalistic by stretch of the
imagination so authoritarian
and like 99.9 of the way there
they're authoritarians who think there's
no there's no truth but power
they claim to represent poor
marginalized people but then beat them
at a moment's notice and threaten their
lives
they're mostly white so they certainly
don't believe anything they preach
it's all the manipulation tactic to
recruit more people
into thinking that they're morally
justified in
say beating a a gay vietnamese
child of immigrants but they're also
mostly pansexual and have a lot of
mental disorders
from talking to a lot of them there's a
lot of also like a proliferation of
transgenderism
not disparaging any of these people just
saying they obviously look for people
who feel
isolated ostracized who have
non-conventional sexual preferences
people who might feel like the other or
the outside that they couldn't somehow
break into society
and i know that they prey on these
people one of the main antifa who
you know he's one of the main foot
soldiers his dust and wheels and he's
actually disabled and at the front line
which is kind of like an iconic picture
that i took one time of of antifa and at
the front line they have
one the one black guy with his shirt off
i don't know if you've seen that picture
and then two people
like transgender people in wheelchairs
and it's sort of this this pushing
the other to the front to make yourself
seem like we are representing you when
really
it's just a bunch of poor white people
who are choosing to reject the system
when a lot of them are college educated
and probably can actually really get
ahead in this site
so i think you know most people who are
listening to this probably know
a lot about antifa but i think that
primer is good for maybe people who
aren't familiar or who think it's an
idea
it is a fact andy noe was brutally
beaten now twice by
antifa they exist they're not an idea
they have brand names they have
offices they have recruiting meetings
they have screeners they have websites
and for some reason you ask like the
democrats like none of that's true
there's no anti there's no such thing
it's like bro there's like an
organization out of portland called rose
city antifa
they actually have like a website they
recruit people they have an email
address social accounts you can dm them
and talk and
yeah meeting spots it's an idea it's not
a real thing they have offices in new
york
veritas has infiltrated them they are i
think crowder has infiltrated some of
these groups
not all of them use antifa in their
brand name but many of them do
now what they're trying to do is
manipulate people into thinking
ignore this there's nothing to see here
ignore the evidence of your eyes and
ears or more importantly cnn just won't
show it
one of the reasons andy's been a major
thorn in the side of these leftists is
that
when they beat him the first time it
forced cnn to actually mention it
oh oh brian stelter gave it a good 10
seconds because he had no choice
like what do you do oh no this guy's
just walking around well
they shifted tactics and rolling stone
that possesses peace put out a piece
saying how a right-wing grifter trolled
the media
that's what they do if you're a
journalist on the left and you lie
and you say all this russiagate fake
news you're a journalist
you deserve a pulitzer prize but if
you're a conservative
and you go down and say that guy threw a
flaming molotov cocktail or police
station they say you're a right-wing
troll and grifter then when you actually
start exposing them
they have to smear they'll lie about you
they have to defame you and that brings
us
into i guess the crux of the actual
discussion and debate about field
reporting
um the risks that people face the
appropriate strategy
and the first thing i'll say is for
those that aren't familiar with what
happened
i was very critical uh and it was like i
think you know i covered the story when
it came out we didn't know if it was
andy or not
and i was like i don't see an upside to
why andy would do this why he would put
himself in this local antifa protest it
wasn't major breaking news it wasn't
national news
i thought he was in london why would he
put himself at risk for this for
something that wasn't like
you know it's like he he's covered all
of the motives the most operandi the
tactics that they've done
so i didn't understand uh you know what
really bothered me
was there were a bunch of conservatives
and i shouldn't necessarily say
conservatives
more like anti-woke personalities a
handful who expressed to me
agreement they're like yeah there's no
way that was andy he wouldn't do
something like that that was reckless
and then all of a sudden you get all
these people tweeting saying things like
oh
you know we no longer agree with that
view because they found it actually was
andy
and even to this day there have been
many people on the right who have
expressed privately to me
their agreement with my opinion that
andy shouldn't have been down there and
we'll get into the reasons why
but now publicly they won't say anything
why well for me expressing my opinion
i got you know thousands of dislikes on
a video people are saying i'm
unfollowing you and they're not they're
they're leaving you know i'm getting
unsubscribed from youtube and stuff like
that people on the right are calling me
a grifter
and i'm like if i was a grifter i would
just pander to y'all and just tell you
what you wanted to hear
like it's not like i'm endearing myself
to the left by saying anti-far
psychopaths
but there are a lot of people i think
who are too scared to actually speak up
and express themselves
so i'll tell you my thoughts on this
we've expressed quite a bit
is that andy's too high profile he is
the
the number one target for antifa
especially in portland
he is as i metaphorically described him
a general in the culture war
who sent himself down into enemy
frontline infantry with no support
no security and then got attacked for it
and i said that was reckless and numb
he wouldn't have i don't think he could
have produced any any coverage of a
local antifa protest
that would have been more than he's
covered in the past
and if there was something there i'm not
familiar with perhaps he wanted to write
a chapter for his book
he could have hired someone and sent
them down so there's a lot to break down
here there's a lot to get into
and for those that aren't familiar
because a lot of people don't seem to
understand i know i'll get flack from
this from people being like cucumber's
stroking his ego but a lot of people are
like tim's
has no idea what he's talking about
because he just sits in a room oh for
about
nine years i was on the ground at all of
these protests across the us
i was at the battle of berkeley like two
or three of them i was physically
attacked like a handful of times i went
on tucker carlson and after antifa
attacked me in boston
and at a certain point i think i'll
agree with megan kelly in her statement
enough is enough
you become too famous people start
searching for you
and you're not there covering the story
anymore so you're not really helping
people understand what's happening if
you are creating a massive ripple by
being there
so what can i do well i could go down to
some of these events and then what
started happening was people would walk
up to me on the left and the right
and then all of a sudden i'm like
shaking hands and high-fiving people and
i'm like this is great
i can't do this job anymore it's just
not possible i've been to venezuela i
got chased out after i was accused of
being a spy i went to sweden with the
no-go zones
i got chased out and threatened i can't
go back to those places
you know it wouldn't make sense for me
it wouldn't make sense for james o'keefe
to start trying to infiltrate planned
parenthood
at a certain point you're famous and
it's time to start leading that charge
that was my main criticism but well
let's discuss
yeah let's talk about this because
something interesting too that i think
people forget is that a lot of people
grift and they use field reporting sort
of there's this way to get in front of
the camera and their ultimate goal
is they want to be a host this is very
common right i mean i'm not claiming
jesse waters or any of these people
grifted their way up but they start out
as sort of a pundit and they're out in
the field and they move up into their
own show
i happen to have had a podcast before i
went out on the field myself it's always
been coinciding
my podcast has always been about what i
see on the field so there's sort of that
duplicity
but someone like andy andy is not a
media personality he's not
trying he's not charismatic he's not out
there trying to start his like this
crazy show he is
in his own right and a bona fide and
genuine reporter and journalist and
author
yes i know your point about his
self-promotion and whatnot it's still a
business model
you've got to make money he's
independent he's not working for any
major network
i know that he he's partially editing
with the post-millennial but i know that
they don't pay their employees that well
so he can't be making that much money
the point being is that when andy went
out that night arguments could be made
that was it stupid
for him sure it was stupid but it's
stupid for every journalist
who would go out because this is where i
tend to disagree people don't realize
that andy wasn't targeted
that night that i believe because he was
andy no initially
he was targeted because he was somebody
that was suspiciously recording events
because antifa have
specific rules that nobody can live
stream or record
their activities which is why people ask
you well why don't you bring security
why don't you use a drone well anything
that shows
possible federal intervention possible
law enforcement makes you a high-risk
target
they will disband they will not act and
they will find a place to go
to commit their crimes while you're
trying to record and expose the event
they will avoid you so with andy going
out there yeah
yeah didn't you just go cover an entire
protest recently yes you were filming
them
yes did they physically attack you no
why not
uh because i was had a face covering on
and i just
did ten what andy had a face covering
well yeah what i was gonna say is that
with portland that's what i'm getting
into with portland is a very difficult
and a tough spot which is how andy
obviously got a platform
because a lot of people do not want to
record and film
portland and tifa might remind you too
they do this stuff almost on the nightly
and so what i think we need to to easily
discriminate against
the fact that initially andy was not
targeted
because he's high profile he was
targeted because he was reporting
on a group that does not allow reporters
to to film or record them like that is
just a definitive fact like it's not
it's not that if you only have 11
followers you're going to have some sort
of a getaway
even reporters i think pdx media who's
also asian who was recording them who
has who follows their rules
he was recently attacked by them too
because they've gotten to the point
where even
the the journalists that follow their
assisted rules like a lot of journalists
do in dc
they're starting to attack them if they
record crimes being committed so this
isn't an exclusive two people that are
high profile
this is reporters journalists across the
board we'll come back to that but you
know that andy does have a podcast
yeah i do know that it's not but it's
it's my understanding it's verbal though
it's what like it's it's mostly audio
only well he stopped doing it in march
of 2020
i think it was like 15 15 episodes yeah
no and that's what i'm saying is that
it's still reporters journalists have
them i'm saying he's not trying to be
like this host of a show he his heart is
in reporting his heart is in journalism
and so to me when you're saying just the
argument i'm just debunking like the
initial statement
is that andy i don't believe was
attacked simply because
he was andy i think he would have been
attacked regardless i think because he
was andy he was nearly killed
they didn't attack him right away they
started asking him questions but they
will attack
quickly if they realize you are not a
reporter or a journalist
that is pre-approved and they ask around
they realize you could be
some sort of antithesis at any point
shape or form
they will attack you they will break
your cameras they will hurt you and i
know this because even when i initially
documented them when i was low profile
they still gave me a concussion when
they realized i wasn't on their side
andy wasn't filming
he was just documenting he was marching
yeah yeah well he wasn't he was
like recording like for his book like he
was just watching things happen
i mean do we have confirmed that he
wasn't recording at all because i don't
my understanding is personally if he's
done that yet yeah well i guess we'll
have to
check that out but i don't think so i
mean i mean that would would absolutely
give you a way in two seconds
the moment you walk up with the camera
they'd be like who are you what are you
doing and why are you doing it he was
marching with them he had
reportedly had a black lives matter flag
over his shoulders wearing as a cape
and then he was wearing goggles and a
mask and what
my understanding is what happened was
and i think this was his statement that
uh one
one guy walked up and started asking him
questions and he said he didn't respond
to those questions so they started
interrogating him more
and then someone ran up pulled his mask
off and yelled that's andy and then he
started running
so the the my understanding is the
initial targeting was simply because he
was out of place
the antivo's probably looking for some
kind of infiltration
and they found andy of all people like
their number one target and then chase
them and beat them and i think it's
fairly obvious it's like it's a strange
thing that anyone would need to say of
course that shouldn't have happened of
course journalists should be allowed to
do it
but i find it fascinating too especially
in this context one of the first
responses i got from conservatives
was uh caitlin bennett well i guess
people are saying she's not a
conservative she's a libertarian
she said quote you know she shouldn't
have been wearing that mini skirt at
night or whatever
correct and my response is like yeah she
shouldn't have i don't understand
like i've never been of the opinion that
a woman should walk through a dark alley
at night with a mini skirt
and not take responsibility for you know
being reckless or unsafe
i i've always been the opinion that
personal responsibility starts with you
first and foremost
so my bigger my bigger issue obviously
antifa is wrong they're the criminals
they're violent extremists
but why why cheer for sending down one
of your most prominent and important
journalists covering an issue by
themselves
why why why celebrate that why not just
say hey start an organization like james
o'keefe did
and start hiring reporters to go down
and do these things and that's exactly
but how would that change like that's my
point is when you see people like
brandon farley or different people that
are out there
that go and record right even like
caitlyn delmeda quickly found that out
when he started reporting for scriber
news
you can be a no name no profile person
the minute that they feel like you are
recording them they feel like that's a
threat
and they think that because you have to
realize too but we're not talking about
recording
you can infiltrate anti-fun be part of
their meetings
yes and no they've gotten a lot more
organized and it's less hyped from the
election
to where there's not as much just
natural grassroots coalition that
they've begun to become more organized i
would say in some ways a greater threat
in some ways less
but they they know who you are and a
group like in portland can
quickly find out who's legit and who's
not and i've seen this
because when i was in uh rochester it
it's usually a riot has about one day
where it's chaos and mayhem
and by the second or third day antifa
moves in and some of these hot spots
they organize they get umbrella lines
they have medics that come out and it
becomes sort of a leftist resistance
some of these more small events are just
kind of people walking around breaking
windows committing petty crimes
and i think what it's come down to is
that it's saying how would him
like this is where my question is how
would andy hiring journalists
be any less risky to those journalists
than andy recording because
from my experience those journalists are
just as capable as being attacked
especially if they find out they worked
for andy let's let's do the logical step
through they they they
there's a journalist hired or contracted
by andy let's say andy starts an
organization or
any journalist they're there they're
wearing a mask they're infiltrating
antifa
someone walks up and asks them a
question and they don't answer then
people start surrounding them because
this person isn't answering
and then someone pulls the mask off and
says
i don't know who that is what happens
next
then who are you if they don't if they
say who are you they'll probably grab
your phone they'll probably punch you
they'll
push you back they'll quickly surround
you start hitting you with umbrellas it
becomes a mob they might start macing
you in the face and unless you run for
your life
and you're able to get away they'll mob
you so just you're down there in
in a black block you're not filming
you're just infiltrating
and i've never seen that happen yes i've
i've been i've been physically attacked
probably like
eight years you don't remember recently
they had the fake the okay so there was
like a fake white supremacist rally in
portland
that somebody trolled antifa on but
people went to go record it was this big
deal
and pretty much people who were just
standing around started getting attacked
even if they were just observing because
they weren't covered in block i remember
watching this
one individual who was who was recording
from far away even ran up to the police
as people started fleeing
because they had what happens in tifa
does is they take over specific sections
of the city so
they'll take over they'll meet like
dupont circle in dc and they'll take it
over and the police don't intervene
and i think that this is my point is
that this the answer that it's coming
down to me
is was it risky for for andy to do what
he did yes
is it incredibly dangerous when you're
high profile to do these things which is
like why i didn't say you were stupid
for saying that this was dangerous or
this was crazy it was
it was also dangerous and i'm not
comparing this it's dangerous to do
pretty much anything
that needs to be done for a nation if
you want to talk about something more
heroic than reporting
storming normandy dangerous also very
risky that's more of a chance of death
than let's say reporting
but even if you're going to be a
whistleblower if you're going to leak
for your company and your risk is just
losing your job
i mean inherently if you're doing any
work that requires bravery or requires
some form of of making an impact there's
usually some sort of a high risk
involved and i think andy knows and
assumed that risk from talking to him
but i also believe that with the idea
that he had talked about being a
political refugee i know there's
truth a lot like that is true i know
they did not believe he was in the
united states and the fact that he was
covered his face he obviously
miscalculated the mitigated risk so he
did
he ended up paying the consequences but
i don't know how that somehow means like
so we'd say well then hey less
experienced journalists go
because i would tell you from having
experience you're just as likely to to
be harmed
in the same way they're looking for andy
they want to kill him
yes like the worst case scenario is like
i don't know who this guy is i don't
like you go home dude get out of here
yes there's truth to that so i'll
concede that andy just wrote
a book i think i think it hit number one
on amazon for
for uh i think it did really well yeah i
don't did it number one i don't know
i think for i don't know how that works
because i think so many people i don't
know i just know that he it did really
well
i just i just you know look i've worked
at a lot of different places
well i shouldn't say a lot i've worked
at like two or two different places
doing
journalistic endeavors aside from my own
company so three or four
and there are certain stories where they
tell you you can't cover this
so like when i worked at vice they were
like hey we've got a story about a bunch
of uh muslim women who are
were raped in these different areas by
these revolutionaries
and they're like you can't do it and i
was like is that what you when you said
when you said that to hear
region typhoid square yeah were you
talking about lara logan getting get
like
no but i mean that happened to her
having a bunch of women i know but i i
think people also thought that was a dig
too
i don't think i'm allowed to say the r
word on your stream right probably
though what i don't know
rape i wasn't talking about i was saying
i'm saying people thought that that was
a jab like that's what i
from talking to people well it came
across like
look look what could happen when you
make the risk making light of it
and then saying it was unbelievably
stupid this is what i'm i think where
people misunderstood you and i'm being
honest because these people
don't understand like the greater i
think people thought it was more just
like a slight on somebody else rather
than
coming across just like hey andy we're
all concerned for you
don't be a dumb don't be a dumb idiot
actually try to do what's right
and protect yourself please because you
can you can afford to probably hire
somebody else and i maybe that's what
you meant
but from what i'm seeing from what
people got from your messages
it seemed like uh just like a slight at
people that that's what that's what i'm
reading in the comments i mean like it's
a fact
in uh uh in tahrir square men were just
like gang-raping women
it wasn't one woman it was like dozens
of women
that's crazy there was a reporter from
the netherlands
who was sent in and got grabbed by a
bunch of men and they shoved their hands
down their her pants and everything and
i said
that's insane so i was doing hostile
environment training because abc makes
you do it and you get all these arrogant
journalists as a weather guy and he was
like i know how to handle myself in
gunfire and i'm like you're a weather
man dude you have no idea you're talking
about i'm not even gonna pretend
nor are you weatherboy but what was
funny was when we were talking about
they did a scenario where they made us
drive to a checkpoint and we're all in
these we're in two suvs when all of a
sudden a bunch of guys surround us with
a bunch of
different guns and start firing them
while they they were blanks obviously
and then they make us all get out at
gunpoint we all get on our knees we lay
down on the ground
they go through us one by one taking all
their belongings and then
all of a sudden they grab all the women
pick them up and carry them off into a
barn drag them off into a barn
where we hear all the women screaming so
all the men are sitting there hearing
the women scream
and the guy with the gun say get in your
vehicles and leave and then started
laughing and making sexual suggestive
gestures and things like that
so we go back to the main headquarters
and we walk in and we all sit down and
then a few minutes later all the women
come back in
and then the guy who's like this fan
like this this like you know former high
ranking
mi5 or whatever british intelligence
goes
these things happen when you're out
there and you need to to understand that
what you experience could happen to you
when someone asked like what do we do in
that situation when they take all the
all the women
and he was like sometimes there's
nothing you can do
and then someone said is this something
only women have to be worried about and
this was the funniest part because
you know running a corporation in the
united states you have discriminatory
discrimination laws
so we immediately was like uh well i
mean
men get raped too uh men can get raped
you know it happens
it does but let's be real man if you're
going into an area where they
specifically target women for sexual
abuse and slavery
then maybe it makes sense not to send
women to certain areas i'll give you a
physical
a real world example a vice reporter
went to i think algeria was the story
and she was told you cannot legally go
down to the football stadium soccer
stadium
because you're a woman and this country
doesn't allow it and she said i can do
it if i want she did
of course she got assaulted and abused
and then she sued vice over it
it just doesn't make sense to send james
o'keefe into planned parenthood it
doesn't make sense to send an israeli
hasidic jew into gaza to report
there are certain things people don't
understand about security and and being
able to get the job done and report on
what's going on
and sometimes you have to recognize i
went to
to sweden i went to the quote unquote
no-go zones i went to one place where i
was escorted out
i went back shortly after on undercover
we walked around nothing happened we had
no issues it was relatively different
you know i went to venezuela this was
where they singled me out by name
i had to flee the country of course vice
wanted me to make the story about myself
said stay there tim
be it make the story oh tim poole's
flight from venezuela i said no
got on the plane very quietly flew back
and breathed a sigh of relief that i
wasn't going to be arrested and put in a
venezuelan prison
so i've been covering all of this stuff
for the past 10 years i was on the
ground in boston antifa attacked me i
was in
occupy wall street when the black bloc
you know extremists physically attacked
me over and over again
and early on they weren't prominent or
powerful they were very weak actually
regular leftist or liberal activists
really hated them in a lot of ways
because they were disruptive but
they had this thing where they said we
must we must uh respect the diversity of
tactics
well as they become increasingly more
violent and the and the followed
extremists gain more and more control
it started to get more and more
difficult for me to even go anywhere
when i was in berkeley
i was just skateboarding not during any
of these protests it was like a day or
two before
and i had some far lefty dudes actually
threaten me and some guy
gets in between he's like whoa well get
out of you know like this guy's in my
face he's young at me saying you're that
you're that trump guy
and then this guy walks up and he goes
are you a trump supporter this is back
in 2017 or 2018 i was like no and he
goes all right you're cool man
leave them alone like how is it that i'm
even just skateboarding around
and these guys are threatening me what
good am i going to be able to do
personally if i just go down here and
what happens is they point at me run
over and start attacking me did you see
that guy the other night who was just
out on a date ended up in jail for like
seven hours because he happened to be
the crosshairs of police
rounding up some sort of civil unrest
and he was on a date end up going to
jail as a
as a provocateur and that is to a valid
point
but i also want to say this about taking
proper precaution like
you can get targeted for a variety of
reasons while reporting on the ground
for instance you can get uh i've been
targeted based off of race like you
mentioned earlier you can get racial
targeting that has nothing to do with
your profile
you get targeted because you look like
someone they think that they know
like when they attacked that guy who
wasn't andy no yes my point is
that you look like someone you can get
attacked simply because somebody's
having a bad day and you're a target but
ultimately
what i want to bring down to this is
that the reason why i i
hate even blaming andy is because
you would think that america like i said
is a serious country and
the reason how this is even possible
when andy went into that
into that nines hotel which is a very
nice hotel by the way it's like a
it's at least a four star hotel i've
stayed there before i had a generous
donor who booked me
a hotel there it's really nice um people
don't know this too that the abc
journalists who cover that stuff that's
where they stay and they all
they all ride first class and they lied
to me on the plane abc did they try to
pretend like they weren't reporters and
try to find out where i was from and why
i was recording and then it turned out i
found out they were abc
just doing grunt weird leftist sketchy
stuff as always uh
but when i but i knowing that hotel it's
like that hotel the first thing they
were concerned about when andy walked in
or ran in was that he had didn't have a
mask on and he was like this is what i
see how backwards these places are like
there's clearly an altercation but this
has become so a part of portland life
that somebody running into your hotel
away from a crazy black block mob is
like your first concern isn't the mob
or the person being attacked it's the
fact that they're not wearing a mask
this is where i'm saying why this is so
effed up though and then it's like well
you got to get out and it's like clearly
you're going to throw this person to the
wolves
but this city the hotel and these people
get sick of it you're trying to operate
a four-star hotel
and you see that these black black
people are walking around with immunity
for well
over a couple years now i mean a couple
get arrested as pity
then you have this stupid attorney
general uh you know and these people who
come out there in the city and they
redefine what crime is based off of
intent and you end up having
a system where police no longer want to
police because they don't want to risk
their lives
because if they get in the way and
intervene and make an arrest there'll be
no prosecution the people will get out
immediately
and so everyone's left to fend for
themselves and so while
the reason why i was like kind of not
shocked by what you said because i don't
give a crap
like meaning if people have different
opinions but it's like this idea of
making it seem almost as if andy was
asking for it
i don't think that's entirely true i
think the system itself
is to blame because i don't think
whether it's andy or a small journalist
the fact that it's i believe equally
unsafe for every journalist
that is not in line with them not not to
the extreme once they find you they
might hurt you harder if you're somebody
who they disagree with
but the fact that this is okay that it's
tolerated that we've become accustomed
to this
i always say this if andy wasn't going
to do this we just had this whole slew
of people
who were documenting these crimes and
andy's just being some puffed up
egotistical
pos and is walking around going well i
for my fame and my gift i need to be the
one to record
fine i see the point but i don't see
anyone else stepping up to the plate
that isn't a complete wussy
i mean shoot when you go down here to dc
i i was
set i was undercover there well hold on
no i'm just saying i watch people tell
people
hey you can't record you got to
understand the rules that they have and
that's the problem is like where are
the good journalists that actually could
do the job in his place
and andy uh asked to come on this show
earlier this year to promote his book
but he was in london for his safety he
asked again and he wanted us to review
his book and i reached
out to him recently he hasn't gotten
back to me but he did want to come on
this show
the the i bring that up um he wasn't in
the country
he wasn't able to do we couldn't do it
he's definitely was in the uk as
in his own words of political refugees
richie mcginnis drew hernandez
you know uh the riot squad chubby
tailcat uh jorge ventura
they come down here almost every single
time they cover a major riot
richie mcginnis came here after kenosha
happened
and he gave us the eyewitness breakdown
of what happened it's one of the most
viewed clips we've ever done it's like
1.45 million views
and then he goes right back into it he
didn't flee the country for his safety
why andy noe has 850 000 followers on
twitter and they're targeting them
so if i'm looking for a good view on the
ground we've got
four uh there's a couple of couple other
people who have been on the ground as
well that we had on the show but the
riot squad
has been at every single major protest
and the only reason i know about these
protests is because
of for the most part richie mcginnis and
the rest of the right squad for sure but
i mean he's the guy who goes down there
and then comes here and says
yo here's what happened and talks about
it obviously i can't go down there
because i'd probably just get shot in
the face
or or beat to a pulp so what can i do
well for the time being until we launch
the newsroom we've been trying to do
this for some time
uh we can just bring people onto the
show to shed a light on what's going on
that's that's
what we're doing why well i get
substantially more views doing this show
and i can't go on the ground because
i wouldn't be able to be there for five
hours filming richie can
then he can come on the show and say
here's what happened he doesn't have the
same kind of
threats against him and he does but he
doesn't have the same kinds of threats
against him that
that i do so if i go down there within
10 minutes
entire stream is shut down ineffective
right and if but
but you have to also realize this too
like for instance like okay because i've
only been covering riots since about
2018
and that's so sad as a country that you
could say that like
you can make a career from covering
riots i didn't intentionally mean to
make that what even my podcast was about
it's called conflict reporting yeah it
was but it wasn't made to be i mean i've
i always wanted to be a wartime reporter
to some degree but i
but i just understand that like when i
met richie on the field
richie had less than a thousand
followers on twitter
and i don't know what his current status
is but i'm sure it's big i'm sure it's
at least in the tens of thousands maybe
wait maybe more
and a lot of these guys when i met them
also didn't have much of a following
except maybe julio rosas
was probably the one person who had a
was with town hall and was like had a
pretty standing
even shelby was like like new and
starting out and we i remember talking
she's like yeah i want to be a reporter
i got out of now she's in the white
house right
yes which is which is crazy so at a
certain point you can't be on the ground
anymore there's a shelf life for
reporters in conflict
so i would say that i this is what i
would say i'd say that there are
reporters who do stay in conflict like
you're saying that do have increased
security
this is a this is a new road that's
being pioneered i think a lot of people
like i said
use reporting to get the job that they
want because i think generals are made
in the trenches i don't think that's a
grift per se
i think that it understands that there's
a lot of ways to prove yourself in a
business if you're in stocks
make a good investment for your for your
clients and make the company a lot of
money show that you were able to take
the risk and the reward
if you want to be in media when you show
people that you're not just in it for
the money you worked for no money
and put your life on the line to get
footage other people wouldn't
it says something about your character
that i think is important and gives you
opportunities in other areas i don't
think that andy's
go end goal is to get somewhere i think
that he really cares passionately about
covering and documenting antifa
i think this is going to be a rude
wake-up call for him but i also don't
think he's trying to
to get somewhere and i mean that
seriously because people always ask me
it's like
well why don't you why don't you report
still well that's a good question
i do sometimes but obviously
things in our country have really
genuinely changed i mean this is where
i'll just concede some points to you
is i got your concerns like bro what the
f like i get that point of like
bro you are a mega person like they will
murder you and i believe
literally just published a bestselling
book about them i believe he could have
died
that night like i mean they their
threats aren't veiled
with with false you know working i mean
where would we be in terms of knowledge
about antifa
andy just all of a sudden his twitter
account was gone he's all of his
reporting all the things he's written
for the new york post or the wall street
journal is gone
overnight like clearly what he's doing
is important
so the problem i have ultimately and and
the reason this escalates beyond me just
like putting out a tweet being like that
was dumb
and then a bunch of us are tweeting
about it is like man the left is really
good at this
they're really good at this they're
willing to sacrifice their own they're
willing to burn down and destroy their
own cities to get what they want
and their tactics work because they have
control of cultural institutions
but right now you have people on the
right celebrating like a strategic
failure
you know a serious risk to uh to the
coverage
to exposing what these people do and
they're happy about it
you know so some someone tweeted it
someone posted on my instagram they were
like you know you're spineless or
whatever
you you tell people to have spines but
then criticize andy and i'm like bro
having a spine doesn't mean be dumb
like james o'keefe i recently said that
dude's got too many spines he's got to
get back surgery to fix his back because
he's one of the only people fighting
but he's not going into these
organizations anymore he hired people to
do it he has he has a
network of undercover reporters because
he's famous
but i i don't want to go back to one
point you you were mentioning like
another thing a lot of people brought up
is this is america like that's the point
tim
you were talking about venezuela and
egypt don't you see how big of a problem
this is
yes of course i talk about it like
endlessly talk about almost every single
day
um but i i've never ascribed the belief
that
women should just walk through dark
alleys at night with mini skirts and
take no responsibility for
putting themselves in dangerous
situations it's always been the left
that said
men should just not you know assault
women and i'm like
that's true and correct yes and also
considering that men do
and there are you know bad people
rapists we'll just say it i don't care
what youtube thinks about the algorithm
uh considering they exist shouldn't
women have a gun
yes they should because sometimes bad
things happen
so yeah i get it andy should be able to
go around without a mask on and just
film it back yeah i'm gonna stand here
and report what i see
and he should be allowed to put on the
mask and try and get an undercover view
of what they're doing
but there's reality there's strategy and
there's a path towards victory
if we sacrifice all of our high profile
individuals for these one-offs where
they can go and and walk into the fray
of the these antifa people are the
bottom of the barrel in terms of useful
idiots for the far left
they are not high-profile individuals
they are not ibra max candy or
you know sean king they're not
high-profile any capacity they have
nothing to lose they could go to prison
and they wouldn't care they're probably
not going to
but they don't care andy no if he stops
reporting then
a good portion of the coverage but they
would care and i think this is important
is that
this is the point is that they don't
care because there are no repercussions
and i know
then your point is saying yeah so then
should there be repercussions
sure but are there no so we have to deal
with the reality
not with the hyperbole of what we wish
the world was some utopia
but this also brings up just the greater
threat that i think is very interesting
is that you could say
maybe that he was being risky or naive
but also remember
the guy has a british accent i don't
think his number one loyalty is like
just to the united states i think he
cares about
covering far-left extremism he used to
cover islamic extremism before
and then he switched to this other form
of extremism which he saw
obviously breeding in the city that he
lived in he was one of the first to
really begin to document this up close
in that city and consistently stay with
it
and i think that when it comes to with
andy specifically recording this
i think he did underestimate them john
hacker who's the guy who helped id him
he's a burn victim
and this is my point about people this
is not you to be making fun of
you know deformed people this is not me
exactly saying what it is
someone like john hacker who i've had
long term conversations with is a
probably six foot three six foot four
heavy set borderline obese burn victim
whose face was melted off has no nose
stubs
fingers clearly somebody who would
probably face scrutiny rejection
sadly in society he has a very important
role for rose city antifa and
if he's watching this he probably even
watches your show sometimes he's pretty
level-headed dude
and i'm saying this and i know that
because people are cruel and if you look
like that
people are not going to offer you
certain jobs they're not going to let
you into society
and this guy now works with antifa
who does an idea per se as people say
not a group but he somehow is their
doctor
and his goal at events is to find people
who are other and to attack them which
is why i said that the profile isn't as
important
as just not being aligned um and i know
this because
what is what had happened over time is
that like i
myself included is that i've always been
very strategic
in what i cover and what i don't cover
based off of
how much i can contribute by being there
and i weigh that heavily
and i mean this honestly when people ask
me why didn't you cover this or why
didn't you cover that i would say well
like why wasn't i you know at this
protest well there was an
act they were searching for me before i
went i had spoken to the police the
police asked me not to come
there was i was going to go i ended up
having friends that went got the exact
same footage
and the police said it was a risk reward
wasn't there it just wasn't they just go
it was we can't we can't guarantee your
protection
and we have reason to believe that they
will kill you if you enter into the
property
so i mean i do take precautions but i
also have taken risks as well
heavy risks in a lot of different areas
i mean even just before
uh the capital stuff that happened i was
just in dc
there was just they wanted to
assassinate me and the fbi asked me not
to come back to the city for some time
because of the active threat of
assassination and i still came back
because the story of what was happening
then was big enough that it was worth
risking my life
and that's why i think the question was
coming which is a valid point of yours
is that does does andy realize how
influential he is how big he is and the
risk reward
people always say well why aren't you
covering portland nightly terrors i go
bro
exactly what happened to andy will
happen to me if i go out there people
don't realize i'm like a six foot two
white guy
i have a pretty decently even with this
gas mask on they always find me
it's it's hard it's hard to blend in
okay it just is
and i think andy might have
miscalculated
how easily identifiable he was even with
coverings on
simply because the fact that he's asian
and i guess you could call this a hate
crime
because i would say that they probably
do target people because they're asian
hoping that they're going to find andy
no we've seen this as a reoccurring fact
they did find him and if you see the
footage it's actually
freaks me out like they're blood
curdling they're goddamn
you come out here and they're like
you're such a little b-i-t-ch and like
like we're gonna beat you up and it's
like bro he's not a [ __ ] like you
literally are gonna
be like they're yelling ex expletives
and whatever we didn't even censor it on
my show because it was just so much
cursing
and we get down into it and you realize
yeah
andy is shaken from this i think andy
people don't realize what i think what
threw me off is that i don't think he
was trying to be the story and i just
don't think
that that criticism that people have
like oh he was he's made it about him
i don't think that that is his intention
at all from speaking to him and i don't
believe this has become a reality tv
about andy and i don't think he'll ever
i don't think he'll ever be back
before before he issued a statement he
already he already booked his appearance
on fox news
did he book it or did they book him oh
they booked him whatever before like
within 10 minutes
yeah laura ingram so uh you know but
what are you saying by that i mean like
i was saying that
uh his recent tweets have been about his
encounter and his interaction and what
happened to him and he's the story
whether it's by choice or not whether
there's anything he can do about it
i think he's in a position now where he
here's what happened to me here's what i
have to talk about
that's it that's the story and there are
a lot of conservatives
who knew i didn't know this i only found
out after the fact
i only found out the moment andy tweeted
that there's a bunch of conservatives
who knew
it was andy and basically had a tested
agreement not to say anything to give
him the opportunity and i i think that's
wrong
i if if i had known the moment this
attack happened that it was andy
i'd have just said it was andy but i
didn't know that so i just
you know gave my opinion on my thoughts
based on what i knew at the time a bunch
of conservatives
knew a bunch of journalists knew and
they purposefully didn't say anything
why
because it's tribalism well i think they
would they wouldn't do that they
wouldn't extend that benefit to any of
these mainstream media journalists the
mainstream media journalists wouldn't
extend that benefit to any conservative
at all this is so this is going to sound
mean but actually at first
i didn't think it was andy because the
guy looked thinner than i knew andy was
last time i saw him
so i was like that i think one of
another
another person wrote the same thing like
that could be andy but that's not how i
remember andy looking
and so i remember andy just having more
weight on him thinking that's
and i don't want to get to that whole
asians look alike thing where it's like
yeah it's probably andy because i just
was like i'm not gonna get into this i
did message andy multiple times and was
like
hey legitimately speaking is this you
and
i didn't find out until like right
before he was issuing his statement
and then i asked him if he would which
was actually a great thing to come onto
my show and to talk about the statement
and have a real discussion because i'm
like rather than just trying to get some
twitter fame would you come on and
discuss this i know he's limiting his
appearances uh
right now from what what he said but
when it comes to booking the thing i
mean
the guy still has to make a living and i
mean you understand too it's just like
when people ask why do you put an ad
in your show or something i mean he is a
dependent he's not getting paid for this
just for whatever and there probably are
a lot of medical expenses in regards to
this
so i don't i haven't seen a gofundme or
anything that he's raising so i'm sure
he's
financially independent and i don't
think it's wrong for somebody to be like
okay
well i'm going to make the most out of
this since this was a really crappy
situation
at least i'm going to shed some light on
the fact that yes this is what i do
i'm not faking it i actually do try my
best i put myself into these situations
and but i do think too that the
tribalism came
simply because there has been on the
left an attack on people who are not
left-wing reporters
like they don't even accept andy noe as
being a journalist
at any point ever so uh i'll first
preface by saying nobody owes me their
time at all
but uh why do you think it is andy
hasn't responded to my
my dms or my request for him to come on
the show
that's a good question i mean he hasn't
respond he hasn't responded to some of
mine too
hassan i mean yeah but he's tweeting
he's active on twitter
he and he's just limiting appearances
but you were talking to him
i mean that's i i have limited limited
conversations in terms of why he
wouldn't be appearing
i know i did talk to him after his
statement after i read it and really got
into detail and asked him
how he's doing and what's going on the
same way when you wrote your tweets i
rather than bothering you i messaged
your producer or whatever and was like
yo we should talk about this because i'm
not into
the bs theatrics of just making things
like online people
realize we know each other we i would
say
i would say friends in the fact that
there's mutual respect
and so these are real people andy knows
not a character in a movie and so
yeah i'm gonna reach out to him and
really try to find out but also too i
mean like i'd consider myself to be
close friends with andy
to a regard because i respect i've
respected him over the years for a while
out of protest it was just me and andy
at some of these things
so i you know developed the friendship
there even though he's you know i'm a
lot further right than he is in term
politically speaking
uh but i mean if he doesn't respond to
go on your show
i mean even just saying i mean look
at it it's because i'm a response no i
know but are you saying it's because
because anything other than the fact
that he's recovering and limiting
like appearances because i even invited
him up to my house and he even said
no he responded well i called him like
like physically called his phone and was
like he didn't respond to any messages
but i physically called him and was like
hey could you come over and he was like
i'm honestly
i am recovering and i'm just like i can
see you in a couple of weeks so that's
that's that's an absolutely fair point i
mean the dude's seriously injured he
doesn't probably doesn't want to hop on
i invited him studio too and he declined
to when i asked him i was like you want
to come on my show like i'll bring you
out and he was like
later i'm really limiting appearances
and i'm just trying to recover and get
things done
so i mean like and i was disappointed
too because god knows i would have loved
andy here because
that would have been fantastic and i
don't mean to disparage andy in this
but that's what people don't understand
about andy andy is a very meek little
gay asian dude like
like like when you meet andy it's it's
not like me where
or you or you're like oh this person's
high strung whoa they're in my face like
whoa this person's got a lot of energy
and it's just like
hello i'm andy no am i bothering you in
your house and you're like
oh this isn't some like aggressive
journalist who's like
mean and like this guy is a tender
gentle person
and i can see why he gets so shaken up
when he gets attacked
because i don't think he even has it in
him to fight back i don't think he's a
violent person
that's why i always get nervous i'm like
bro why don't you carry a gun like why
don't you carry
knives or something like that two
seconds oh well
i mean when it's legal to carry i carry
you know my fear with andy is he got so
famous when he got the milkshake thrown
at his head with like cement in it or
something
so famous from that injury that now in
the drug world they call it chasing the
dragon you're always looking for your
next big high
and you remember how you got your last
one so you kind of re-replicate it and
so even if it's subconsciously he's
allowing himself to get hurt
for the publicity and that's that i
don't know about that
i don't know it's not really famous
after getting hurt last time and he got
really famous this time again
i think left up the first time though to
be honest the brain hemorrhaging like i
i
i know they say that there was no cement
in the milkshakes and i have no idea
what the truth is about any of this
stuff
because i've seen heard all sides all i
know is he did have a lot of medical
expenses and i did verify those because
that's kind of how i met him was just
what actually happened the first time
and i don't think this is comparable to
the first time in terms of actual
long-term damage i mean
the first time he was in a big public
protest with a bunch of regular
journalists in the day tops and
in the during the day and they just
started beating the crap out of him they
knew him
yeah yeah they've been they've been
trusted it's because of that one
instance they said that he was working
with the proud boys
and so i know but they say they just
just like they say he sends kill list to
adam off and you've heard that one
that's why they don't like him now
because they say he works with white
supremacists and he sends them kill us
of ntf and gets them killed and that's
actually what they hate him for now and
if you go around they pass out flyers
that andy knope works with adam often
which i can verify is false
and andy no never sent kylis to a
supremacist group why would an asian guy
work with these kinds of people it
doesn't make sense logically but also
fictitiously speaking it's the boogeyman
thing
do do you know how much they hate do you
wanna hear this they they hate andy so
much this is really interesting
i went um i went undercover
just to do what he did to go attend a
big rally uh a counter rally against
proud boys up in portland
and i just do this to monitor situations
and and it's a luxury that it has been
afforded to me working with blaze tv and
they you know it's been a good show
slightly offensive has been doing well
and i'm really grateful
for the support and i've been able to
travel and go places and observe
and i went to this big this big rally at
a park
and i don't think people know how much
they hate this dude someone on the
microphone and we're talking about maybe
1200 people 800 to 1200 people black
block that's how many people
attend these things was like just an
andy knows name
and there was the largest collective boo
i have heard
in a long time everyone's like boom
people are yelling
kill him boo kill andy no and like i'm
going
i started looking around i'm like if
they only knew i was here
and that every riot squad member is here
right now
in like many of them don't know
who andy knows other than his name which
is why they attacked random asian people
thinking it was andy
i was i was at a cernovich speech in in
new york
and one person i was just standing in
the middle of the crowd of all these
people filming
and then one guy yells that's tim pool
don't let him film you
and they all looked around confused
because they don't know anything it's a
cult man they just follow the leader
so then all of a sudden some random like
leftist walks up to some old man wearing
a vest who's a photographer
and starts yelling you're the problem
you're the reason belvan screaming at
him and the old guy's like
shrugging like i i don't understand i
thought it was hilarious because
they didn't know who tim poole was other
than someone said tim pool bad
and then it was funny when some guy the
guy then no not him him and he points at
me you know what i did
i just turned and looked around like
where where is he and then
finally he's like him and he walked over
and then they surrounded me started
saying thing like you're cernovich's
friend and all this stuff and i'm like i
don't even know the guy
and then some woman i back away from the
crowd and i'm just standing there
filming
and some young like 20 year old blonde
woman goes to security and starts making
a bunch of crazy stuff about me like
this guy
has been sending our names to white
supremacist groups he's trying to get us
killed they're coming and looking for us
and they're like i don't know what
you're talking about fortunately for me
i have a bunch of press credentials and
i was like ma'am none of that's true and
i like show her my creds and she's like
i'm so sorry
but that's that's that's just did you
make it up i will say
i will say that that is that is the best
tactic and kind of what i was talking
about people not being trained
like i think one of my favorite things
is i actually grabbed a microphone when
they started yelling fascists go home
i actually took the microphone from the
guy and started yelling it with him like
fascists go home and they actually and
it's like it's on video and i'm like
yelling at
it was about me and it was like fascists
go home and it just
everyone calmed down because it became
very confusing now yeah no no
and it's like why is this guy now
yelling i guess we got confused
but i mean like yes i i want to i just
want to bring this
up with this now having happened
i know that a lot of people saw the the
possibility they saw people like you
early on they saw people like andy like
myself people who were reporting that
were blowing up that were getting jobs
and careers and working in media
over going to these events over
documenting things in conflict
this is not the first time this has
happened this has happened for decades
and decades
in the media and a lot of people during
the trump era
sort of were like oh i can do that too
right i'm just going to grab my phone
and i'm going to film which is totally
great
i'm so glad people want to get out there
and they want to document and they want
to film things
i think a lot of people quickly find out
the mitigated risks are high
and the reward is very low up front the
chances of your footage actually being
seen by a lot of people
relies on it being shared and retweeted
the monetary exchange is next to none
unless you're good at negotiating for
for rights to your footage
and also on top of that the physical
just risk
of going and getting beat up and hurt
either by police
you know i always remind people like my
worst injury doing this was from dhs
not from like department of homeland
security is the one who hurt who's hurt
me the worst
not actually antifa what was the
situation
um it was at the federal courthouse and
they just shot the with a gas powered
like point blank with a like whatever
flash bang in my shin and just cracked
open my shin
my leg and just it was just really gross
and [ __ ] and bloody and
just just end up on the floor in the
middle of rise this is the biggest issue
i'm having with the situation is the
young
new people that are inspired and want to
get a camera and go out there
and the basically it's like a divulgence
between idealism
and pragmatism or idealism and realism
like the idealism is
journalists should be able to go there
and do their thing and not get hurt
i get it babies shouldn't starve to
death people should be able to lay in
the jungle and live
forever but they don't uh if you go into
the wrong place you'll get killed that's
the reality not and the idealism fails
there so if these young people come up
and they think that idealism is what's
gonna
get them they're gonna get find
themselves in situations where they get
hurt and
i really want andy to understand that i
mean
jay daniels right was he got shot uh i
mean
he's going to like rally and just like
to piss them i mean i'm not not accusing
anything i'm saying
just kind of go in there to be a part of
this this this thing
and he ends up actually losing his life
from from this
blm antifa guy who ends up aaron
danielson yeah yeah but i think he was
like nickname was jay
oh like jade yeah yeah but he i mean
people like you're saying that like the
risk
people end up dead badly hurt and you
see people i mean i've seen people
really damaged i always wonder what
happens to certain people like i've just
seen people bleeding out on the floor
going
what happened to that guy yeah and and i
mean and i mean this seriously because
kailyn the other did you see
in la how they got him and they could
get they concussed him they beat the
living snot
kalyn delmana from scriber you've had
him on your show yeah um
but blm and antifa mobbed him in los
angeles a few weeks ago really hurt him
pretty badly
uh and he wasn't really doing anything
they just saw him talk to someone
that they said was somebody you
shouldn't have talked to and so then
they beat him
up over who he just spoke to and that's
my point about people who don't
understand like you might even just talk
to the wrong person on the scene
and you end up a victim because while
caitlyn has profile
caitlyn is by no means i would say high
profile and that's not bad that's
actually to his advantage
but just just having that risk of not
knowing that he spoke to the wrong
person
led him in grave danger and i would say
lucky to be alive
because if you hear on the video footage
when he's getting beat up they're
basically saying brother
you're lucky to be alive because if if
this were any other day we would
kill you and we're not doing that
because we're going to let you go
but you better leave and nobody cared
nobody came to his he's not he's a
non-partisan
reporter too you're a subscriber it's
like they even have a meter where you
can rate their articles if they're too
liberal or too conservative
and they add adjustments and corrections
i mean like the guy's not partisan
and this is how they treat somebody
who's out there so
i mean that's where i just getting this
idea of connecting with andy is like
i don't know if this gorilla journalism
is really a thing and also i don't
really know if it's safe anymore in
these cities and i don't know if i would
encourage people i used to encourage
them
pick up your phone pick up your camera
and go film and now i'm like
i don't know if i'm gonna get sued for
saying that because the liability
of watching my friends get hurt watching
people get injuries
and quite frankly the best way to not
get hurt now is probably just to be
black
and i would say that you're probably
your best chance is black except
my producer savannah hernandez got
jumped
reporting in austin really badly and got
hurt and got her phone stolen and
everything
and she's half filipina half hispanic
and she's
uh she looks more asian than mexican and
she's a girl
and she's like i don't even know anymore
i'm like andy's asian gay like i'm like
maybe if you're just a big black dude
they won't mess with you maybe like i
don't know
but i want to i want to move on to this
story because uh i'll put it this way
for those that are just tuning in um
that are able to because internet was
struck by lightning
uh and a lot of people are like let me
let me help with your network it's like
it's not a networking problem it's like
the line that literally goes to the poll
that carries out the fiber optic signal
is struck by lightning but anyway i
digress
um you know we're talking about
journalists going on the ground
and the safety of those journalists what
makes sense for them
and maybe it's time to stop acting like
we're talking about protests
maybe it's time to start acting like
you're going into a war zone
across enemy lines quite literally if
these are people who have killed
this guy in portland is dead he was
killed by a guy with a big red salute on
his neck the black lives matter
communist symbol it's the red salute
it's crazy
shot a guy in the chest killed him if we
know that we are involved in what people
have called a cold civil war
that was this princeton professor a
democrat by the way said it was a cold
civil war a couple years ago
and so the point now where people have
literally been killed and many of
some many others have gone to prison in
these in these fights when you start
treating these things like
there's there's no america right now
maybe people just don't want to accept
it maybe we're desensitized to it but
let me explain something
i've talked for a while about civil war
and the left loves to disparage this
concept because they need
to make sure it's ridiculed if regular
americans wake up to the fact that their
way of life
their jobs and even their race just
based on their race they're being
attacked and disparaged
having their resources stripped away
well they might actually get mad about
that
so the left loves to say it's not true
it's never going to happen well
let's go through a few things you've got
in washington they're they're mandating
critical race theory
1619 project level stuff they're
literally telling children a
different history of the united states
that makes the u.s seem like
evil like an evil empire they tell kids
that
the the country was founded in 1619 as a
slaveocracy
they are literally flying flags of their
ideology at our embassies
the embassy flies the american flag
because the american flag represents all
americans
half this country more than half
actually do not support
black lives matter you have youth over
half now
well it's over half because some are
neutral and many oppose it
so you've got like 48 supporting 48
opposing and then like 3 percent neutral
which means
more than half do not support and nearly
the same amount oppose it
yet our embassies are flying a flag of
an ideology opposed by half the country
you have schools putting out revisionist
history
you have the fleeing from from you know
the states are hyper-polarizing
you have institutionalized ideologies
that are willing to lie
cheat and steal and accuse a president
of being a russian spy accuse people of
being white supremacists
and their goal is to make sure regular
americans don't
realize it's happening which brings me
to the story i want to show you
kids network nickelodeon rolls out pride
month content
with imagination i can be anything i
want now i don't care
too much like you know pride content
lgbt rights and all that stuff i've
actually campaigned for many of these
organizations don't you want to arm the
trans people
absolutely 100 percent they should all
have guns
however the issue i'm talking about here
with this story is this
in the video they show what's called the
red salute
you know the red salute is it's right
well you just did it oh no
that's right yeah and the chinese
communist party i love how you can do
this but you you can't you can't
solution you can't do the funny mustache
man but you can do this which is
actually worse but
yep that's where you go they killed a
ton of people
they're all they're all manipulative
authoritarian psychopaths and genocidal
maniacs
and right now the chinese communist
party when they swear someone into the
party they
they perform the red salute nickelodeon
is showing the red salute to children
they're getting them to identify with
this ideology so it's time to stop
acting like antifa on the street are
anything other than
enemy belligerence they go around
destroying
buildings burning them down they've
literally killed people
i can already hear the left saying but
what about the far right who've killed
people
yes they're lunatics and bad as well
lock them all
up and throw away the key now we now we
can deal with the thousands of people
across this country black clad
antifa who have been going on causing
billions of dollars in damage
and we can ask our state department
politely please don't fly the flag
of this cult dogma ideology that half
the country does not support
by all means you can believe in a bunch
of crazy things some of these people
like flying
some of the people in america they like
flying confederate flags not a big fan
some of these people like flying blm
facts flags oh youtube's gonna get me
for that one
not a big fan just drop the l that was
the internet connection yeah
some of these people like flying flags
of a bunch of different ideologies
there's a flag for for islam or symbols
for these things
and i believe people should be allowed
to fly them i don't think our embassies
should be flying flags that do not
represent the country
however as we now know because this
woman on msnbc a new york times
editorial board member said she was
disturbed by the sight
of people with american flags because by
showing those flags they were basically
saying it's my country and not yours
which is a paranoid delusion
but it comes a certain point when you
have
conflict in the streets for years where
people are being killed
skirmishes not a whole lot of death but
some death physical destruction of
property
attacks on on governmental institutions
and yes there was the the riot at the
capitol
you have these things happening and
united things happened americans
have are frogs in a pot boiling could
you imagine
if it was eight years ago if all of
these embassies around the world start
flying the black lives matter flag
people would be like whoa whoa what's
happening but they do it one step at a
time
and now americans are like no
everything's normal and fine like antifa
is a normal thing i'm used to it by now
yes you are used to the fact that black
clad
leftist extremists go around throwing
bricks through windows and burning
buildings down
for over a year consistently and
sporadically for the years before that
that's not normal and now nickelodeon
is running commercials promoting that
ideology
there was on disney channel cassandra
fairbanks tells me about this they're
running
anti-trump commercials for children what
do you so so you can call it whatever
you want you can say we're not in a
culture war or conflict or a civil war
people have died already the conflict is
only escalating
and now you have joe biden you know
engaging in
these behaviors you have our embassies
around the world flying a flag that
doesn't represent this country
and i'm like now we're at a point where
the american flag
is being flown and just below it black
lives matter
how long until they say we're going to
take the american flag down just for one
day
in honor of black lives matter half mass
how long until they say well we're going
to put the american flag at half mass
but
we support you know black lives so we'll
fly black lives matter how long until
they say
well we don't want to use the words
we're going to do the fist how long
until they say
it's the communist salute and you're
going to the gulag
perhaps it'll never happen perhaps it's
all just chilling out
and this right now this everything we're
seeing with nickelodeon promoting the
red salute
with these children's programs saying
orange man bad with violence in the
streets and andy no getting beat up
maybe this is the moment where
everything stops and tomorrow everyone
calms down
the only problem every time i've said
that it just gets worse
and keeps escalating you're kind of
feeding my conspiracy theory
that black lives matter and antifa are
working together
i don't know how you guys feel about
that black lives matter gets the picture
on the flag then antifa uses that
picture to justify their behavior
yep they co-opt their movement though i
think it's the antifa
members specifically and i always just
say members because they are they are
allegiant to an idea
who are the actual people who are
committing a lot of the destructive
damage at these events
uh but they use the cover of black lives
mattering to
be dismissed right because their their
goals are cultural marxist goals
are to relieve the the oppressed and so
somehow
americans should feel like small
businesses being destroyed is a justif
justified response to trying to help
black people which is absolute stupidity
the fact that people think that black
people need help and it's their job to
help them
is so asinine and ridiculous i mean
i have become so emboldened with
everyone talking about how black people
need help and how black people need this
or that
it's like you know what how about you
stop looking at black people like a
monolith of just like this group of
people that need help and start
realizing
people are individuals and there are
cultural trends and things that can be
addressed
but it's just if we could stop calling
them black people that would also be
great and then we called collabs people
of color too
you know it's even more except for
asians are no longer in there because
they're white people
listen they don't care about those
people the left does not care
it is white progressives mainly their
upper class or from the suburbs
they don't care about the black
community they don't care about the
asian community they don't care about
ending asian hate they can march around
all day and that would stop asian hate
flags and then go beat up andy no sorry
it doesn't work that way
they're perpetuating it because what
they really want to do
regular people are the target so when i
say
civil war they say what a crazy [ __ ]
because they don't want regular people
to actually listen to what's happening
so i don't say it all the time but i say
it a lot because i think a lot of people
need to recognize what it is
semantics are important the left will
call their no-go zones autonomous
zones it sounds so funny it's autonomous
zone
say no go zone they're not autonomous
zones they're areas the cops are scared
to enter
where people are being killed george
floyd square they call it no i call that
an extremist no-go zone that's all i
call it that's it a far left extremist
no goes on why
people are being shot and killed bullets
are riddling up these buildings and the
cops don't want to go there
but but here's the point though that
flag is the american flag now whether
you like it or not because
intersectionality this idea of bringing
minority groups together
for one common goal is the result of the
reality that multiculturalism
does not work it does not work to have a
country
that is divided up into sub classes of
people who want a different outcome for
the nation
at equal or greater powers or strength
that does not work with a bio spirit of
the nation
of people wanting an outcome if you want
an outcome for a nation to be successful
or an empire this is why empires
when they over reach or overexpand their
territory kind of falling apart there's
too much to manage too many wants and
desires from too many groups
and they lose focus but i'm just saying
this that that flag
and the reason why it keeps expanding i
don't know if you saw today that they
changed it again
to add a circle for intersex people on
the left-hand side
the point is actually pushing the
rainbow out see yes but this is my point
is this intersectionality is great
because what they see as being this
white conservative straight roadblock to
this
one world order that they think is a
nationalist identity
they need to remove that but they
haven't had enough power to remove that
and even the boogeyman of white
supremacy
is pretty much ridiculous but what they
do is now they incentivize you
though saying like you're just like you
you think it's cool to be an american
and patriotic
wait till you're gatriot you know and
you actually get on this on this train
and you join us have you ever had a
weird thought about the same sex
oh you're probably queer you think black
lives matter you're now a blm supporter
and it's like these like basic things
that humans have gone through
and they start to procure you into
saying your identity is with us and they
create a
sub culture from america that is the
amalgamation of all of the micro
cultures and in fact they
have become more influential and more
powerful than this white
subdominant silent majority that
everyone talks about that doesn't
actually exist
and so you know it's funny and then
whenever they talk about this right like
the white replacement theory or these
things they'll say these are conspiracy
theorists
but then you hear the left talk about
this stuff like to understand the future
of the countries to understand
immigration and to understand people of
color moving in and they talk about
these things and when you bring them
back up
you get called a conspiracy theorist why
it's because their ultimate goal is to
subvert and undermine our culture our
society
they're using that by taking advantage
of these people who are outcasts
they're creating that mixed with a lack
of assimilation and they are dominating
and now they're flying their flags
in our embassies that is we've been
conquered
so today i was actually listening to a
podcast to current events podcast
um i don't know if i should name it but
um the person i was listening to
said that the black lives matter flag
was taken down
like the pride flag was taken down
outside of the u.s embassies not because
they didn't want that ideology in front
of the us embassies
but because they didn't want to give
people the foothold to say i would like
to fly
the gads didn't flag this was their
reasoning and that just
floored me i was like this is consistent
with everything i know about the way
things is going and i want someone to
fact check me on that because i didn't
have to chance to look it up for myself
i just tried to and wasn't able to find
like a current article
but this is something that makes perfect
sense to me like they are unwilling to
give an inch of ground
they're just saying we're not going to
fly the flag because it might
give conservatives a way in which is
troubling to me so we have
we have this story from military.com
this is from june 1st gadsden flag patch
on airmen's uniform wasn't authorized
officials say
and it's a photo of a guy and he's got a
gadsden flag uh patch
i don't care if it's authorized it's
like a symbol of virginia there's like
you can get a license plate in virginia
of the gadsden flag
why wouldn't someone be able to to have
that
political i suppose they say u.s
strategic command on saturday tweeted a
news release promoting nuclear launch
security measures along with a photo of
captain alexander
garland a three uh 341st operation
support squadron nuclear crypt
cryptographic
cryptographic operator inserting a
floppy disk into equipment at the base
according to the photo caption he was
wearing the patch on his operation
camouflage pattern or ocp uniform in the
photo
the incident has been addressed with the
members chain of command
and regulations regarding the wear of
authorized patches in accordance with
air force standards
are being reinforced throughout the wing
a spokesman
from the 341st said adding the patch in
question is not authorized to be worn on
air force uniforms
proper ware of the uniform is a vital
element of good order and discipline
which guides our strikers daily with the
execution of no failed missions yadda
yadda we get the point
there's a story i think i think it's do
i have it pulled up from snopes
navy seals ordered to remove don't tread
on me patches
snope says false it's not true navy
seals
they they it was it it didn't happen
they said this from 2013.
now they're saying don't try to so this
is back in 2013. they weren't ordered to
remove them
okay there's a lot that could happen
between now and then and and who knows
what may have changed but now this one
guy in the air force was not authorized
to have
a patch so at some point did they revoke
authorization for having this
did they say you guys don't got to
remove it from now on no one's allowed
to have the gadsden flag
meanwhile you can rest assured that they
will be flying pride flags
but they don't wear pride patches on
their
i mean really you're not supposed to
wear any patches that aren't
aren't a uniform i don't know it's it's
so
absolutely disrespectful and disgusting
i'm just going to say this
this movement has nothing to do with
homosexual rights or with black people
or whatever
sort of nonsense you want to say this is
a political subdivision of the united
states that has wanted power
and like i mentioned earlier has felt
like the white conservative straight
person
has been the major roadblock block the
person with values traditional christian
values
these these conservative values
constitutional values
and they know that you know they say
this is an interesting thing with the
1619 project that a lot of people
will get pissed off about one thing that
i can agree with critical race theory on
is they do say that america was made by
white people for white people
and i've read the documents and before
1965 it specifically states
like for our posterity and i've read
some of the critical race theory and
i've looked at the documents they didn't
forge them
if you look at the history white people
did write and
make things for their posterity now
after 1965 especially today if you think
this country somehow benefits
white people directly and that that
somehow hasn't changed you're not living
in the current country that i'm living
in i need to just make sure i make
something clear
the dod did ban pride flags right so i
just want to make sure that's clear
because i don't know anymore this is
this is you know
i'm just saying i'm you know we're
bringing up that they're criticizing the
wearing of the gadsden flag
and so i want to make sure my point is
clear cause i know the left is gonna be
like tim's claiming they're flying the
pride flag but that was banned that's
not what i'm saying what i'm saying is
because what lydia was pointing out
because they don't want people doing
either flag they say you can't do these
flags anymore but the gadsden flag is
literally a symbol of this country the
pride flag by all means have your pride
flag it is not a symbol of the
foundation of this country
i understand what it represents and i'm
more than happy to allow it isn't it
like based on our previous conversation
about what we would the ideal of what
the country is
is pride in these things that we're
exporting out into the rest of the world
have become
just as much a part of the american
identity and who we are i mean they're
rewriting history about who was queer i
mean i remember i was in the seminary
they tried to convince me that jesus
might have been gay no no no you see
this this is what's called a hostile
takeover
when they tell children the country
wasn't founded in 1776
the country is being erased people need
to say it dude
the cold war is still going on the
soviet union ended
because of their their kerfuffle in
afghanistan and the mujahideen and their
lost war in the 90s dick
but the cold war didn't end the
communist
obsession is still present it might have
lulled for about a decade or 15 years
but now man
it is and it's not just russia the
communism is not a russian thing
it's it's a dangerous collectivist
ideology i mean china
is communist they're pushing an ideology
and people in america now our children's
programs are showing the red salute
uncritically to children to get them to
embrace this stuff
the flags of our country the gadsden
flag a symbol of the revolution don't
try to me is now considered hateful and
unacceptable
could you imagine the founding fathers
but for all their faults they created a
country that has improved the lives of
people around the world for better or
for worse americans a lot of bad things
but it's through the founders and their
documents and the great activists and
political leaders
we've made one of the best countries if
not the best country in the history of
the planet
and now could you imagine the founding
fathers were like we set forth this
great nation
and we bestow upon you the
responsibility to make it and improve it
the founding fathers didn't like slavery
but they didn't do enough to stop it
because they were scared
i shouldn't say all the founding fathers
many of them were worried that if they
opposed it
the south would not join the revolution
and then they wouldn't be able to
actually break away from from the crown
you know what i think that's bad i think
slavery was immoral then i think it's
immoral now and there's a lot of bad
things done by a lot of bad people and
of conquest from a lot of nations around
the world
so all we can do is say as a country
we've done better but think about what
would happen
after fighting for independence they
would learn that within
only a couple hundred years the country
could not maintain its national anthem
the country could not maintain its own
history lessons
the country could not maintain pride in
its own
flag and not the gadsden flag the
literal american flag
remember when colin kaepernick
complained that the nike shoes with the
original flag of the colonies was racist
so they pulled it
now we're having sporting events sing
two different
national anthems the nfl announced
they're gonna you know
they have the black national anthem and
the and the american anthem
how is it that we couldn't even maintain
a country's values and culture for a
couple hundred years
let's just be honest here it's because
we were sold out to some
bs in 1965 they appealed to the
christian nature of the white
race of the of the country and said
you're obviously not racist you guys
don't you guys outlawed slavery this is
civil
rights you want to be open you want to
bring people in this also got changed in
the 70s and 80s
well let's change immigration let's
start helping people let's make right
the wrong way
that we've created what i'm saying is
this what about and they're going to and
they're going to assimilate no but
they're saying
they're going to say oh yeah people will
assimilate we'll be one nation but that
opened the door where they were where
right now what's happening is get more
specific what do what specifically
you're talking about well i'm talking
about when the immigration laws were
changed when we had this similar bio
spirit and there was
there was this majority of people in
every nation whether it's religion
race it's culture there has to be shared
value but what happened is this post
1965
with a change of immigration and you
look as the country changed everyone was
like yeah
i love everyone who's not white i'm not
racist that's rude
to just be mean to somebody because of
their race and they're going let's bring
these people in let's assimilate but as
we've seen
constantly with the change of
immigration i would say even in
i know you're not a christian yourself
but with pushing god and demonizing
christian morals
and morality a few other factors as well
including i would even say
the hostile takeover government in some
ways and our intelligence agencies
came in and we were sold this future for
america which was a total scam and i
believe had communist influence because
instead of
pushing people to assimilate and to have
this great american spirit
all we've seen is people are being
pushed to identify more with where they
came from
what their even ideas would be on race
so also on sexuality right
right i don't i don't think immigration
is the issue i think it's divide and
conquer
and you need as much points of division
as you can but you don't think
immigration that you don't think
communists
like immigration they take advantage of
i think they're like illegal immigration
i think they want to sow open borders
policy because
what what i what i learned with sweden
when they let in a lot of the somali
migrants in the 90s
the problem was they didn't try to
assimilate they didn't give these people
an opportunity for work they were
actually extremely racist in sweden
so what happens is they bring all these
refugees in and then feign
how how anti you know how how how much
they they love all people
and then they put all the people in
these urban centers with no support what
happens
well people from somalia speak somali or
you know i'm not entirely sure the
language but they don't speak swedish
they don't they don't they aren't able
to get jobs they can't make money they
struggle and they're forced to live off
of subsidy from the government
this creates a pocket of people who
don't feel like they're a part of sweden
then their children are born these are
people born in sweden
swedes who are white call them
immigrants when they go and visit their
family in somalia they're called swedes
so now they have no home no identity
they don't know where what what they
represent other than their small
neighborhood
that's what happens when you don't give
people a chance so you say simulation
what does that mean
it's a chance to actually function
within the community to succeed
so immigration it's fine because
immigration means we control our borders
we have planning we say okay you're
coming here we have an excellent place
for you
there's this this city that's growing
rapidly they desperately need your skill
set you will
you will live very well you have a great
family welcome to the american dream
shake the hand what what we're seeing
from the left
is a conflation of the legal immigration
which is good with the illinois illegal
immigration which is bad
when a bunch of people come here risking
their lives getting hurt
and then going to random places all
legal immigration is good and i think
that that's why legal immigration is a
key and a door
to give the communists more room to
divide and conquer because that's my
point is what we're sold is
is somebody's coming from another
country they share your values they
share the american spirit meanwhile
when they're brought here they do feel
ostracized and i will turn this before
someone tries to make me appear to be
racist
their studies have been done on white
american expats who left the country and
have lived in places like japan they are
not happy with where they live
they feel isolated they tend to hang out
in the same regions they tend to
recreate
america where where they live they tend
to be depressed at a higher rate than
the average american
and they tend to be unhappy because
japan is a homogeneous place and there's
a culture
and they tend to not fit in and the
number one reason why i'm saying why
expats don't fit in
is because in america it's seen as being
really great to share your political
views you actually
are like seen as sort of being brave and
in japan you will be ostracized
there's a word for they're racist well
how is that racism
japan is literally racist they're an
ethno state and they do not
they they don't how is that how is that
racism of a homogenous
japanese culture wanting to preserve a
certain ethnic group for like have you
have you been you've been there right
yeah
and how well ordered the society is i
mean they are just they've been this way
for thousands of years they've been very
protectionist
i don't i'm not offended by the way they
run their country my point is is that
from reading from understanding
communists it's not that
my wife's an immigrant from from a legal
immigrant from australia i'm not against
people coming to other countries i'm
saying that what i'm what is important
to admit
is that the change in immigration
systems in the united states
was used by communists and other people
to divide and conquer and it is to this
if
you have someone come to the border the
united states who doesn't speak english
and you say we are going to find a
beautiful place for you where you will
succeed
this one individual enters a community
of five thousand people
what happens to that individual they
they they become part of the community
they start they they improve their
communication skills they find work and
the community maintains its values and
this person adopts many of those values
and they all succeed and they all share
in the in the wondrous fruits of their
labors
if you have a community of 2000 people
and you bring in
5 000 people of a completely different
ideology what happens
it it subverts the community taking away
their values and instilling new values
on top of them
immigration can be done right if it's
done legally which is why donald trump
said they can all come here but they got
to do it legally why because it means we
can plan effectively
to make sure they succeed bringing
people from an area that's suffering
because they have problems and putting
them in an area where they have no
support structure
and no ability to bask in the american
dream just means you get ghettos
you get people who are suffering in a
new place in a new place where they're
just suffering with no opportunity
illegal immigration how do you explain
sweden and some of this redistribution
where these people don't want to
assimilate like the idea that they don't
they don't actually want to and that's
what i was saying about the expats for
the united states
they don't want to assimilate into
japanese culture so why would you bring
people like
my point is is that is that i am not
hateful towards any people group
but when you look at this this is my
point about giving communists open doors
i
i sense that the cold war isn't over
isn't over at all and i think that
communists have come in
this is why it's not just illegal
immigration and legal immigration
even with this whole weird sexuality
thing i mean people have kinks and by
god
well i've grew up in l.a i know people
do a lot of things
that i wouldn't even do myself but they
keep it to themselves
but this idea of making your sexuality
your identity and moving in this
mode where you make you know separate
your gender and your sex i mean these
are
very foreign non-western ideas that are
that are strange and i'm just saying
in all of these ways i feel like we've
given we've given too many open doors to
the communists
where i don't see us returning and i
don't think that legal immigration
i think in theory is good i just think
that it has been misappropriated
misrepresented
and i disagree with trump's opinion on
that do you remember when the liberals
used to say
what you do in the privacy of your own
home is your own business not the
government's that's the liberal
california i grew up in yeah me too yeah
yeah now now it's not now it's that's
why usb centrist i used to be okay with
liberals they were pretty chill
of course well no the issue is that you
go on reddit right
and every day i go on reddit i read all
the stuff
boy do these people have no idea what's
happening in the world there will be an
article and they'll say republicans want
to ban
teaching history of slavery like msnbc
reported that and it's like that's
literally
never happened no republicans ever
proposed that so a republican comes out
and says critical race theory is a
racist historical revisionism
and the left then tells all of their
blind sheep
they're trying to ban teach ban teaching
the history of slavery
it's like that's that's a gross
mischaracterization of what's actually
happening south lake did it right right
right
by right by where i live i don't live in
south lake fantastic place yeah they
said no they banned anti-racist
curriculum but they really just banned
critical race and so what happens is man
you get
regular people who are like well i don't
like racists
yes anti-racist but if you act it's it's
it doesn't mean anything
so antifa right these people literally
follow the doctrine of fascists
almost to the t then they go but we're
not nationalists
okay fair point um but you still believe
everything else the fascists believed
don't take my word for it david great
with the late david graber rest in peace
was the one who came out on twitter and
said there's an element of the left that
has adopted the fascistic philosophy of
there is no truth but power
what do you think it means when they
come out and say there's no objective
reality or that two plus two equals five
they're constructivists they believe
there is no truth but power a cortenate
of fascism
however they've abandoned the idea of
borders why well i mean hitler wanted to
take over the world
they would prefer a one-world government
of authoritarianism where
there is no truth but power and they
have the power so there's not a really
big difference between them and the
fascists that's what people need to
understand about the red salute
the communists and the fascists the
communists and the fascists were
fighting in europe at the turn of the
century in 1900s and into the early
1900s
they were both despotic psychopathic
groups who wanted to beat and kill each
other
and one side lost in europe and one side
lost in russia
after the fall of world war ii we got
cold war for
for for generations we're still in it
now with china
these are despots they believe in in
concentration camps
i understand the united states has not
done well themselves but hey we're a
heck of a lot better
you know it's funny because we think
we're this perfect nation we're not we
have massive corporations
the government teams up with facebook to
ban and censor speech but we have
recourse
a federal judge in california just said
california's assault weapons ban is
unconstitutional hey we have those
protections
it is a hard fight every single day to
defend our rights but in china they
don't have that no have you seen what
happened to jack ma
i mean he's he's the richest guy in the
world or one of the richest men in the
in
in china richard's got china government
just basically grabbed him
put him in a on a farm or something was
like you've gone too far we're taking
your company we're giving it away
so they broke his entire uh 900 billion
dollar industry is now
the value's been cut in half because
china is just doling out you can't be
a hero in china right because because of
because of hard times and this is what
i'm trying to say is this is coming from
somebody
who who literally just to tell the
audience who's probably unfamiliar
was actually consistently bashed by
people for being too center on most
issues
and always like calling me you know like
a pussycat you know
but without the cat and they were always
coming down to me why are you so nice to
the left and this and that i'm going bro
i'm born and raised
in l.a i live in hollywood bro like i
don't even i'm the most
like right-wing person i know and i
still i'm not right enough for the right
people
but as as i was tolerable and tolerated
things and did what they said to
tolerate i watched people gain power to
where they started making life miserable
for those they disagreed with
and i started seeing the world that
these atheist
authoritarian communist sexually
confused people were bringing to the
country
and i don't like that and when they say
hard times create strong men it made me
confront
my live and let live sort of
pseudo-libertarian ideas
and i said the people that i thought
were wrong are actually most
most right it's that tip jar for alex
jones that joke that meme
where it's like he was right jar and
then it has it's full
it's people that i used to disagree with
i started reading i started
understanding and i realized
that sometimes what sounds good is not
what's right for the country and the
communists have used the good benevolent
heart of americans to come in and to use
institutions against us even our trust
of the government because our respect
for patriotism
and our fbi and our thoughts like our
fbi wouldn't you know politically
persecute people from january 6th so
they're americans they're patriots they
wouldn't
treat amer other americans like that
even if they committed crimes that
benevolence of our hearts has been taken
advantage of
we with immigration with taking god out
of school separation of church and state
with understanding multiculturalism even
with the gay pride stuff originally it
was like dude
don't you just want gay people to be
able to do what they want to do in their
closet
and you're like okay fine go ahead and
then now it's like yeah if you won't let
them have sex with your kid you're the
bigot
you know and so that's my point that's a
little a little extreme
no but i'm we're getting it sounds
extreme today but you know what sounds
extreme today is tomorrow's normal
is that we have become accelerationists
and that's my point is the more i sit by
and go
i'm okay with these people i'm okay i
feel like that mean where i'm like okay
things are not okay
this is not good and i've had to come to
terms with ideas that i'm
uncomfortable with i've had to accept
truths that i wish weren't real
and it's i've had to take a more of a
stand and i can't be a centrist anymore
because i don't even have a label i just
can't be in the center because these are
enemies of the united states that have
hijacked this nation
they have used these institutions
against us and i'm firmly going to stand
against them
i know i'll look like the villain today
but you have to be a villain today to be
to be tomorrow's hero because the media
won't
go to super chat so uh oh yeah we gotta
go to super chats
so uh if you haven't already smash that
like button and for those that
are uh upset with the constant loss of
the internet here's what we'll do
we record this so we'll just upload the
full corrected version after the fact
so that everybody who actually wants to
watch the full podcast it's recorded and
in high def
and that'll be our fix and i'll tell you
this um
send us an email to jobstimcast.com if
you're on if you're a
an i.t specialist we'll fly you out
immediately first thing
and you can try and fix our struck by
lightning internet
so we've got uh there's a bunch of
workarounds and and and backups we have
but our satellite backup is down
our cable line backup is down and we
even had we even had a line run
from the house above ground as an
emergency backup it's all just fried
so when you send that email put it
specialists in all caps on the subject
yeah yeah do it to it and you'll have a
flight first thing in the morning
because we'll go through those emails
asap
and then you'll be here by like one or
noon or if you live on the east coast
you can drive out and we'll
we'll we'll uh have someone come out but
let's we'll read super chats and then
again for those
that uh just want to watch the podcast
because there's gonna be a lot broken in
this one because they're just dropping
off
we'll upload the full version uh to to
youtube
clean uh but go to teamgas.com become a
member we have a bonus segment coming up
at timecast.com for members only and now
let's read
some super chats beef swellington says
youtube upset with you
they stopped notifications for you
that's right which is why we're setting
up timcast.com because
like any other anti-establishment
personality
you know we're not long for the world of
youtube and if you put all your eggs in
that basket you are going to be in
serious trouble
all right all right let's see what we
got here
joseph cole says hey tim and co been
watching for five years now please go
download stream or watch tom mcdonald's
new song snowflakes on all music
platforms
right on i hear good things jake dog
says
i am on elijah's side cause sav heart
puppy smiley face never never simpers
do people simp for you yes and i don't
like it don't sip for producers that's
right it's not nice
all right tyson jalil says tim used to
be on the street reporting
now that he's rich it's not okay for
others to do so just get security
sure thing millionaire tim uh
andy noe just sold like a best-selling
book i don't think the dude's poor
um i don't know if he's a millionaire
anything like that it's just this
example of a cavalry commander you may
this point are leading the charge of the
cavalry
they do it for years they get so good at
it then eventually they they become the
general that goes behind the lines and
decides
where the cavalry's gonna charge while
the infantry is moving up and they
become a tactical mind and that's
where andy is right now i think carter
strasser says tim do you support
negotiation with terrorists
how much should andy negotiate what's
your line who benefits most from
negotiation
uh i don't think i've ever advocated for
andy walking up to antifa and trying to
draw terms on what is acceptable
i just think it doesn't make sense when
one of the most prominent personalities
in the culture war
goes by themselves into the fray of
enemy combat infantry
who are not prominent and aren't doing
anything particularly newsworthy
and then risks a very serious and
important piece of the culture war but
hey look it's frustrating to me to see
that many on the right
they're not as good as the left the left
knows how to organize
they know how to infiltrate destroy and
rebuild and they're doing it
methodically and they've been doing it
for a long time the new york times
they go in they take over they do these
same things in fact we had we had a
couple people here talking about their
organization
how the woke came in and tried taking it
over how they resisted it
the last thing we need is these very
serious tactical
failures do you think that people on the
left are high iq low eq
and the people on the right are low iq
high eq in general
no i think people on the left are
conformist collectivists
and people on the right tend to be
individualists and that's one of the big
separating
separators which means on the right
someone's going to say i say we all go
in protest and there's going to be
a bunch of disagreement from people i
don't know about that that doesn't make
sense for me on the left they're going
to say everyone shut up and do as you're
told i'm going to go yes
and they're all going to wave their
fingers in the air like this so they do
the borg they'll go mike
jack and then everyone yells mic check i
think we i think
babies should all go out and protest and
everyone goes yeah
and then they all go march they'll get
free donuts for their jobs they get free
ice cream they get free donuts you know
pathetic losers it's need a reward to be
to to fall in line with the state they
do though
whoa corn pop says jordan peterson
moderated a debate between fouchy and
rand paul
on the pauls to the wall podcast must
listen oh that's not real is it
i got to look it up did you guys you
guys got to check out freedom tunes
because i voiced fauci and it was like
the most fun thing ever
and we recorded actual video of me doing
the voice and with sheamus directing
and then sheamus has that that bonus
segment up for his patron so
freedom tunes that's right i was the
voice of fouchy
droplets it was fun yes
uh morgan grace's have you heard the new
song by tom mcdonald called snowflakes
wow
he hits it uh he hits it all on the nail
i've heard some of it i'll check it out
it's really good you should have him on
your show he just
it's it's he's so busy you know i know
uh he's in california
nice yeah it's hard for people to travel
especially when they got crazy schedules
and like this dude's massive you know
what i mean dude i want to hear the most
embarrassing thing i had him on my show
remote
because he was he was busy and uh in the
middle of our interview the tricaster
just died
oh no and so the it's like we're in such
a good conversation then it just cuts to
me and goes
during the filming of this the tricaster
died and that's it oh
wow thanks for watching well our
internet got struck by lightning so
i mean what do you do sometimes you're
just things just like things just short
out and you're trying to
show you know what to do yeah but we but
we record backups backups on backups on
backups
i got so many backups i even have mobile
backup nothing worked
back in the last year our internet would
go down i beg satellite and we'd be good
now the satellite's not even working
they must just there's somebody just you
know
some alien is like they activate all of
his internet
he's too smart he has too many and
that's how aliens talk yeah
i've been watching so it was really
funny you know i used to watch star trek
the next generation before like every
episode
somebody commented tim you really need
to watch star trek sg1
and the weirdest thing happened the
schedule for the channel that i normally
watch switched from
star trek to sg1 and now all sudden i'm
watching star trek s3 sg1
all the time good show by the way we may
as well use the power that's right
here we go raymond field says
you should look up the beef of h3h3 and
stephen crowder it's hilarious h3h3 says
we should trust the government and calls
crowder dumb because he doesn't
that's what i was talking about last
night oh man yeah yeah
dude are you do you like ethan klein i
don't know a lot about him
he's just like a comedian personality
right no he's i would say he switched
okay because by the way not only has he
said the n word
unironically on air multiple times and
the f and
f a g ot or whatever i hope i spelled
that right but he said he said he says a
lot a lot of bad stuff then he switched
because it was cool to be edgy and then
when it became advantageous to not be
edgy
then he became woke and then also with
that wokeness and trying to appease his
audience which you should never do
he became totally unfunny not creative
and with his soulless wife he tries to
put on a show and i feel so bad for him
because
he gets millions of millions of views
but he switched from like like appealing
to edgy people who thought to like now
he's doing stuff with like trisha
the like he basically makes like dumb
content for dumb people
because he's appealing to wokeness
rather than he's actually smart
theoretically speaking but
it's just sad when people throw away
their creativity to appease the crowd
and then they end up like looking like
losers my issue in crowder's issue is
that he was telling people not to do
their own
research i have a huge problem with that
i don't care where you stand we get it
we got a great one here laura says tim
just admitted he thinks women who get
raped walking in clothes in the dark are
personally responsible great take tim
thank you i appreciate it i think
i think it is a good take because um you
know i've always maintained my
principles and so like what
one story i tell is that one day i was
late for school and i was late because
there was a train and in chicago you
know these trains man they cut through
the neighborhoods and you just sit there
for half an hour sometimes
and so my dad was like why are you late
and i was like it's not my fault there's
a train and he goes you know the train
tracks are there
why didn't you plan ahead for the
possibility the train would stop you
from being there
if you don't take this into
consideration it's your fault like
there's no excuse for
every day walking past the train so i'm
not saying women are responsible for
getting raped that's not what i said
i said that at a certain point there's
some responsibility
in your own safety i'm not going to walk
with a bag full of cash in a dark alley
at night
don't walk in a dark house any night
anyway yeah well yeah i mean you can
take the garbage out yeah but i also
have guns and i moved out of cities
so the point is what i said first
of course the the responsibility in the
problem comes from the criminal who
should be condemned for coming the crime
i'd love to live in a utopia but so long
as criminals exist and we know they
exist
at what point do we tell someone look i
know it shouldn't be this way
but you should probably have pepper
spray a taser or a gun whatever's legal
in your jersey problem with idealism is
the movie industry
really has put it in people's brains in
the video game industry that like oh if
you just
believe that it can be this way it will
one day when you persevere
like when you see reality and people
just get mowed down and smash it
what i really see an idealism is a whole
lot of should and you know who agrees
with tim's take on not walking down a
dark alley is camille palia who's
actually a feminist she completely
agrees with him
and it's not saying it's deserved it's
saying that you need to be responsible
and i see a lack of that on both sides
of the aisle
it's like imagine if you had a deposit
from your boss you're like you were
going to starbucks and they're like take
this five grand go to the bank
and you're like okay i'm holding a
deposit bag
i'm gonna try and i'm not gonna hide it
i want people to be able to see it
okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna you
should live in a world where you can
show the bag i should be able to hold it
over my head it should be
and when someone comes because i decided
instead of going the normal route to
walk through the dark alley to the bank
and someone runs up and snatches it from
me it wasn't my fault no you should be
able to do that
absolutely but you should be able to
make yourself vulnerable in front of a
hungry elephant
no hold on it isn't your fault that
somebody ran up and snatched and stole
your money
but there are things you can take
responsibility for
you shouldn't have to hide and do these
things unfortunately
criminals and murderers and rapists are
real things could you imagine if someone
was like
the crocodile shouldn't have bit me it's
not
fair that i hear about this woman she
got attacked by a crocodile she was like
you know diving or whatever
or how about the woman who jumped in the
spider monkey cage
oh right now i should be able to i know
but dude what's the reality
do we do do we live in this world where
we believe that humans are all saints
and angels and that crime doesn't exist
no the universe wants
it's like imagine you you go you go look
when someone goes mountain climbing or
like hiking
and they get mauled by a by a panther or
a you know mountain lion
i don't say it's their fault for going
hiking i just say like man it's
unfortunate because
these things happen but you recognize
that these people take those risks right
some people do things they wear like
shirts with eyes on the back they carry
air horns or weapons or some kind of
repellent
because there's a real issue with
getting attacked by a mountain lion
they're rare it's rare we don't want
these things to happen
but why is it then that people have bear
mace it's because we accept that
sometimes you go hiking
or you live in the wilderness bears
might happen could you imagine if
someone was like i shouldn't have to
have bear mace
the bears should just stop attacking me
i mean i mean yeah but
you know so the bear attacks you i say
that's the the first and foremost the
bear attacked you
humans do messed up stuff there are bad
people that exist we have a
responsibility to ourselves to remain
safe
we blame the criminals by sending them
to prison we buy products to defend
ourselves and technology and armor and
things like that
to be responsible but we're more into
blaming victims today than we are into
blaming perpetrators specifically in
political crimes
if if the victim is in the political
right almost always you'll find the
narrative
tends to be somehow that they are the
perpetrator and i think that's why
people get sensitive about issues and i
think like just like with the feminist
thing
it used to be that women were never
right and so there was a big defense in
the feminist movement towards defending
women
because it's like oh of course you're
going to mansplain me a woman's always
wrong
now we've come into the opposite swing
where women are always right
until proven wrong and so then that's
where you get the backlash and anytime
you start making somebody
seem like they can never be the victim
or and they're always a perpetrator is
when you have to kind of
if you're going to fight for rights have
to come to their defense and right now i
feel like specifically even with the
with the rape
thing and with women wearing skirts like
that's just not even the conversation
anymore because
women are encouraged to dress like hoes
just to wrap this conversation because i
know we need to get moving
i do think it's strange that an entire
movement that believes that everyone is
bad and terrible and horrible in every
single way
also simultaneously believes that you
should just be able to dress however you
want and do whatever you want and face
absolutely no consequences to me that's
such
a dichotomy of ideas doesn't make sense
all right let's read some more power up
pika who says
america isn't perfect america was both
on ideals ideals like truth justice and
freedom
we are only human we won't live our
ideals 100 of the time
but that doesn't make the ideals not
worth fighting for in response to the
ccp brainwashing
i do take issue i don't agree i think
america was founded on subterfuge and
murder
um it was not a lot of standing out in
the open and saying what you thought it
was a lot of secrecy
uh all that the founding fathers worked
underground no one knew what they were
doing they snuck in on christmas eve and
murdered a bunch of people when they
were asleep like it was
no no idealism is not why we're here all
right
um pnbw says tim you really need to get
the stream fixed it's skipping and
doubling back on itself really bad i
don't know if that's your internet or
youtube
it is that our internet was struck by
lightning just blame cicadas
yes i mean i don't know it was a really
bad storm and also on the internet
stopped working
and then we had the guy come out they
came out really fast shout out to
antietam
they were quick we didn't think that the
guy came literally like within the hour
and he was like yo you're what your line
is
fried i don't know if it was like a
lightning strike or something we got to
replace this
it's like okay so that probably
negatively impacted our fiber line as
well
but good luck getting verizon to respond
because it took like six months to come
to come out in the first place
when they had us they assured us for
like a month we might have a better
chance of getting struck by lightning
again
than having verizon come out yeah i
think you might be right twice that's
right isn't that the way it works yeah
calling every known line and there's
just no one there i really don't want to
manifest that but
these varieties but it's okay it's okay
because we just don't have to pay the
bill anymore oh
what happens is they probably won't come
out but within a month when we don't pay
they'll call us and be like why didn't
you pay back well we've been trying to
get you to come to fix it but we have no
internet it's not working and they'll go
on they'll be out then someone shows
up yeah all right let's see
a lot of people saying please brian says
please love of god let me fix your
network i.t systems engineer
i have literally designed and managed
data centers okay brian
send a an email to jobs at timcast.com
and uh we will have you on a plane first
thing in the morning to come out and fix
the internet because it is a priority
for us and there's nothing we can do
but maybe you can figure out what the
issue is for all i know
there's something internally that got
fried by the like a surge hit it and we
don't know what the pieces are it guys
uh dealing with some
you know very serious stuff so uh you
know we we need someone who can come in
and help fix this stuff
all right sonny james says what ian said
made me think
andy no got famous from a milkshake
hitting him in the head at a protest
today a journalist getting hurt or even
killed covering a protest riot not part
of the msm
probably wouldn't make the rounds in a
24-hour news cycle that's why i say
we're frogs boiling man frogs in a pot
the nickelodeon thing made me realize
that it was like a
hot splash of like shock like when you
see that black lives matter fist that
that
the red salute at the end of a communist
symbol it's like a transgender
drag queen drag queen um talking
i had the it on mute actually while i
was watching it but just like
and then you said it again it only
influences your kids
don't call it that how many different
names does it have the fact that
the red salute it was created by these
people called the red salute
just like the nazis try they stopped
calling it the nazis
they called the roman salute shut up you
know what it is it's also the fascist
salute as well now it is the game now
it's the gay
pride salute i mean i'm just saying i
mean the homosexual communism
i can say communism is gay and i never
thought i would have to say that because
communists used to kill the gays but
then now the gate they're using
right right right very weird stuff and
also it only influences your kids it
used to make me angry
but the reason why don't make me angry
anymore because what makes you angry if
your kids watch that stuff
and so it's like you it doesn't
influence me because i'm clown-pilled
and past the black pill where i'm
laughing at them because we know what's
coming we understand what's on the
horizon we're preparing
for these types of things the potentials
of what these people might do to us
on a defensive measure some people
offensively but most importantly
speaking it's like people like go like
well it's nickelodeon it's like dude
just stop watching
tv boiling the fact is
that if they were putting swastikas in
children's messaging we would all be
rightly freaked out
they are doing the same thing it has
become mainstream and corporate to fly
the red salute
and people say tim's being disingenuous
it's actually the black power salute
yeah and and what did the alt-right say
when they marched we're not
they said they said they weren't doing
analysis they were doing the roman
salute
i don't care what you call it we know
what it is we know what you're doing
and people need to stop using the
language
of the cult and the communists they're
literally flying the red salute that's
what it is
that's what it's for the chinese
communists to do it when they're in doc
when they're sworn in
and now people in this country don't
want you to say it because it's bad but
it's their symbol
i don't even know why they use it maybe
they shouldn't like it's it's over it's
in your face
but they do and what happens is frogs
boiling regular people including
conservatives
adopt their language autonomous zones
black lives matter fists
good point i don't like calling people
white and black i feel like that's
adopting their language
homeless ghetto instead of autonomous
zone remember they couldn't even figure
out the name whether it was chaz or
chop or whatever but go zone do you know
what's so good
is this producer i know randomly he
created a server in gta 5's name is
brian
that he's recreating the leftist world
of america he recreated chaz and chop
it's this whole custom thing he actually
invited you
he wants to do a live where we all get a
gta 5 and stream it and he's recreated
everything like a giant pepe statue like
in the middle of the city
and like it's the most it's the most
insane thing and i go he shows me the
skate parks he recreated your skate park
he showed he showed me the the chop and
i was like bro that looks like a
homeless encampment he goes that's what
chaz always was
yeah all right we got mcfly and jesse
ryan says long time listener first time
caller
i drive all over the country for work
and i would like to be a contributor of
good news
on the ground how real life actually is
from major cities and small towns
i believe it would add to your show let
me know i don't think we would do it
on on this show but it's something we
would absolutely produce
for members of timcast.com as a show it
would be great to have someone going
around and talking to local shops asking
about the economy about products
just focusing on the news what do you
think about what's going on with with
with dc
with the with the national guard with
january 6 etcetera so mcfly and jesse
ryan send us an email to pitches at
timcast.com
james says our founding fathers signed
their death certificate with the
declaration of independence
if your safaris uh if you're
safaris of being filmed in your actions
you know what that means
but they did many of them who signed
died had their homes burned to the
ground
their their families were ruined it was
a brutal and bold thing they did
all right zach says i'm not getting
notifications for your live stream
make sure you click that bell button
well it doesn't matter once youtube
decides they don't like you they don't
like you and then you go
you're gone all right
no one to use says tell tim we aren't a
constitutional democracy we're a
constitutional republic
that i misspeak in my previous segments
i think you explicitly said that
yesterday
you ain't black says second day in a row
your live is glitching and not loading
they are coming for you tim no our
internet got struck by lightning i can't
do anything until verizon comes out
but we can't have that i.t guy come out
first thing in the morning whoever it is
and it's an email
kyle ellis says tim all these flags
flying over embassies god forbid they
fly the palmia flag
something that has been important to
actual patriots for well since america's
been fighting wars
that's right here we go omega rasetsu
says former army regulation 671 dictates
what can be sewn onto uniforms the
gadsden flag is unauthorized
af regs are based on army regs well
there you go
mavro saint john says the biggest thing
i have ever disagreed with tim
is the idea about him stopping playing
world of warcraft because people can
just be hunters in real life
people play video games to be things
they can't be irl well of course you
can't throw fireballs in real life
people would have fun with that so you
play virtual reality but
you can get really like dopamine and
endorphins and all that stuff from being
physically active
you you don't need video games they're
fun i know i get it
you know you know you know i'm really
disappointed no sequel to child of light
that's a great game i haven't played it
it's good it's
fantastic really really great simple
single player rpg rather short story
but fun good fun good good good timing
system for the rpg
are you a gamer elijah no the
this world is my role-playing game i'm
not even joking
i have so much fun in this world like
running around and just seeing that it's
useless who wants to live forever
i'm glad god gave us an expiration date
because i mean i don't want to die
before my time whatever that means but
let's just be honest like the idea of
living to like 80 is pretty good
that's great oh yeah i'm hugely into
genetic therapy and like nicotinamide
mononucleotide
the regrowth of the telomeres i'll be
done
at 80 just give me covid all right gold
818 says tim fellow long islander over
here and the thing that mara gay was
really complaining about
was that take back our school's rally on
long island the event was led by sean
farage of loud majority
he would be a great guest for your show
and lydia keep pushing those buttons
i will write this name down
okay let's see what we got here brother
stratos says i actually agree with you
tim yeah well there you go
eliza bass manikam says elijah
is there a pattern of antifa members
growing up without siblings or just one
sibling
i am wondering if sometimes a
contributing factor is not being part of
a family team
i've never been around these people but
i can't assume they have strong father
figures
right that's all i would probably make a
supposition there
yeah all right let's see
garhant says stating the left advocates
for child love isn't a stretch
children are allowed to consent to
reassignment surgery
the left educates five-year-olds mnf
together on
some of these things i can't say on
youtube the left in ca is making
uh sex ed mandatory for sixth grade
yeah well you know there's a lot of
there's a there's a lot of things that
it's interesting because conservatives
were like i remember you know 10 years
ago if we do this what's next
this and the left was like that's a
fallacy and then like a lot of those
things actually happened yeah
all right let's see
says just remember the metaphor if the
united states is a steel sword
immigrants are the carbon atoms within
in moderation they strengthen the blade
but too much and they form crystals that
weaken the whole structure
interesting what is this
man xt says fresh and fit once called
you the walter cronkite of this
generation that's a tremendous
compliment i love that
but uh who's fresh and fit i'm not
familiar there are oh uh oh i don't know
what's up sounds cool though
i like i like the idea of fresh and fit
that seems pretty cool they are a
podcast
rainforest says it is stargate sg1 not
star trek sg1 no your sci-fi did i say
star trek sg1
uh you did and i actually didn't know
because i was actually like oh i'm gonna
go watch star trek i don't know well
that's good because i was saying is i
used to watch star trek the next
generation and now i'm watching stargate
sgt
oh it's stargate yeah i used to start um
i don't have any job offers to say like
posted jobs but if you know some good
epic sci-fi stuff
email me elijah at slightly
offensive.com because i need more
stargate well there's my there's one i
need these weird
the movies i need a list sg1 is great
okay but we'll start there
yeah it's really good no job offers but
it's close i'll take your opinion
dominic bristow says tim get the
starlink beta i have signed up for
starlink a long time ago
elon musk uh send me starlink please we
will never have this problem again
that would be fantastic dude we had uh
when forrest was here from recoil mag he
had night vision
oh my gosh and you look up at the sky
and i could see the satellites dude you
could see starling
like amazing it was like super high-tech
um night vision goggles i mean you could
see
shooting stars yeah dudes like it's like
if you want to make a wish don't go
outside and look up
get night vision goggles go outside and
look up and then you're like okay i say
i wish for this i wish for that uh
wish for this and this and this and this
and this yeah bring a list yeah bring a
list because you'll just that's non-stop
it's amazing where'd you get those no
there's a guy who had him he was here
oh bro you could see the satellites
you're like is this government issued or
is just somebody buying i don't know
no no no legit one's real on top they're
expensive you can buy them like 10 grand
or something
crazy it was so cool
boiler says i assume you have security
procedures in place in regards to
bringing in an i.t person from the
outside
you know i don't think i i
yeah we do i'm not entirely worried but
uh
definitely um i i know a bit about my
infosec so
i'm not we're not gonna let anybody come
here we're gonna obviously i assume
we're gonna get a big list of people
saying they want to come and they'll
have to go and and vet some of these
people before they do i keep hearing
fauci's voice now when you talk you're
dropping no eye droplets
uh storm viking says ian the founding
fathers didn't murder
anybody it's called war please learn
history and stop with your liberal bs
america was founded on freedom and other
amazing ideas
i mean what about the savages oh i mean
the native americans did they call them
that was that murder because they didn't
consider them human
i don't know i'll just say this though
that the whole idea of us massacring
what is this sorry uh not really true i
mean i mean they were not
exactly the most non-hostile people oh
they were vicious yeah cannibals
or michael alvarez says he got out there
steven crowder literally just got his
live stream deleted today for telling
the truth i'm over youtube
what is the truth can anyone tell what
do you say the truth
but they didn't give him a strike
apparently not dude he's like got one
more strike and then they're gonna like
yup that's why you all need to go to
timcast.com and become members
so here's what we're going to do um
[Music]
we are going to uh well i'll read this
one more just because someone says
who is john galt says hola not sure if
my super chat got through did the
network go in and out looking for
admin with both it experience and
economics i am your man send an email to
uh jobs at timcast.com
uh go to twitch.com become a member
we're gonna we're gonna wrap this up
quickly so that we can send we can
upload the recorded version immediately
we still
we still have to record our bonus
segment for timcast.com members so
you can follow us on facebook and
instagram at tim cast irl help share our
videos helps grow and then we direct
people to the website
new websites coming up in the next week
or so with a newsroom and then we're
going to be hiring journalists and
building up that newsroom so it's going
to start very you know slow and
but we're going to we're going to be
getting there it's really hard i am
doing all quality control myself which
means
we can't grow as fast as many of these
companies you know what they do in new
york they hire someone to go hire 10
people and they just trust them to do it
i can't do that so we got to make sure
we've had all these people it's going to
be difficult and it's slow growth
but uh that's the plan man timcast.com
become a member you guys are going to be
excited you're going to love the new
website
it looks amazing i'm super stoked for it
we have an auction
system because we're gonna start doing
events as soon as we can
which may be in the next couple of weeks
so people will be able to come out here
and we've got a new security system and
all this really great stuff and you know
we're armed to the teeth all that good
stuff so uh
you know people will enjoy hanging out
here for our special live events
and uh you can follow me personally at
tim cast we will be back live tomorrow
but
you want to shout anything out elijah
yeah well first of all congrats on the
website people don't realize how
important it is actually to support
there because
believe me people will be gone quicker
than you think if you guys want to
follow me if you're still watching
whatever thousands of people please go
to my youtube
slightly offensive subscribe there we
are so shadow band i mean and i mean we
have emails where they've called us
borderline content
which means that we are close to the
border of fun
so we have a lot of fun go to slightly
offensive or type my name elijah shafer
follow me or wherever else
and also please support tim's website
too because
i'm just an appeal to this is just
saying i've had a lot of videos pulled
and taken down too
and the overtune window keeps changing
and so who knows it might be crowded
stream today
this stream tomorrow it's like you've
got to subscribe to the websites but
also subscribe to our youtubes until
they access
you can follow me in crossland.net and
at ian cross on social media i said
earlier that you can't be a hero in
china
uh i kind of i don't really believe that
i think you can be a hero anywhere
although i do find that that government
seems to be making it challenging for
people to rise up right now
but maybe china maybe a greater hero
will emerge from the uh the tumultuous
environment become a great hero
subscribe to slightly offensive on
youtube
awesome nice squeeze it in there and you
guys may follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids as i attempt to gain
more followers and sour patch kids and
it's epic your twitter is
one of my few like pleasure twitters
other than you and and
greg kelly like i'm glad to be in the
same class as greg kelly
right on go to teamcast.com become a
member and we're gonna upload the
correct full recorded version of this to
youtube right now and then we'll see you
at timecast.com around 11 or so thanks
for hanging out bye guys